Open Source ist lustig.
So, wir haben ein Pad.
In der Tat.
Ich habe hier mal zum Vorschlag reingeschmissen.
Sascha, du könntest über das reden,
was du auch schon beim Mobile Camp
mal erzählt hast, falls du darauf Lust hast
oder Bock hast, drüber zu reden.
Es gibt bestimmt ein paar Leute.
Und genau, du darfst auch gerne
ein bisschen was über deinen Job erzählen,
falls du unbedingt Bock hast, oder über Schweden,
oder über Scooter fahren, oder so.
Auch noch lieber.
All of the above.
Was immer euch interessiert.
Wollen wir noch etwas vorbereiten oder wollen wir einfach anfangen?
Einfach anfangen.
Wir bereiten uns doch nicht vor bei diesem Podcast.
Warum habe ich den Eindruck auch?
Weil es so ist.
So, das ist jetzt der obligatorische Moment
für...
Hi Hendrik!
Ups, das war falsch.
Oh, so sad.
Hi Kilian!
Hi Hendrik! Hi Sascha!
Hallo Kilian und Hendrik!
Und
Na komm jetzt!
Los!
Ah!
Was macht der gerade?
Ja, ich habe noch nie versucht
die Musik einfach live in die Aufnahme mit reinzuspielen.
Das ist aber cool. Das gefällt mir.
Das soll ich öfter machen.
Na, deswegen ist es ein bisschen schwieriger los.
Du drückst, ja komm,
und dann geht die Musik los.
Die Qualen klangen nur ein bisschen durch.
Ja, das war schieben.
Ich habe quasi den Track gerade direkt an diese Stelle
verschoben, wo es losgehen sollte.
Macht bitte alle eure Geräte aus, wir nehmen hier
einen Podcast auf. Jawohl, Herr Lehrer.
Ja, also wir sitzen
diesmal hier wieder zu dritt. Nachdem wir es schon
ein, zwei Mal angekündigt haben, haben wir es endlich mal geschafft, den Sascha
zu uns einzuladen. Hi Sascha.
Nachdem wir Sascha in jeder letzten Folge angeworfen.
Ja, das fand ich sehr nett.
Sascha ist einer unserer treuesten Hörer.
Vor allem, weil er lange Dienstreisen in Kauf nehmen muss, wo er sich Flugzeug langweilt.
Sag mal, Sascha, was machst du eigentlich, dass du die ganze Zeit so viel Zeit hast, akronymisierbar zu hören?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, die ich mir auch öfter stelle.
Das war meine, oder?
Ja, ich arbeite remote für eine sehr, sehr nette Firma mit dem Namen Neo4j in Schweden.
Die meiste Zeit bin ich in Dresden und arbeite von da.
aber so einmal im Monat
bin ich da eine Woche ungefähr
und entsprechend
verbringe ich sehr viel Zeit,
oder verschwende ich sehr viel Zeit an Flughäfen.
Wenn ihr euch für
Storys von den Flughäfen
Dresden, Kopenhagen, Frankfurt oder München
interessiert, ich hätte ein paar.
Gibt es viel in Dresden? Passiert da wirklich was?
Du hast mich durchschaut, da passiert nichts.
Ja, aber ich wollte gerade sagen,
es ist ein Flughafen Dresden, es sind drei Flieger am Tag.
Fahren die Leute in Kopenhagen mit dem Fahrrad
über das Gate?
Es gibt Fahrräder, ja.
Aber noch habe ich keins nutzen dürfen.
Muss man in Kopenhagen,
muss man in Dänemark einen dänischen Führerschein haben,
um so dein Fahrrad bedienen zu dürfen?
Glaube nicht.
Wie, du durftest keins benutzen?
Ich würde gerne mal auf so einem Flughafen
so eine Tour machen,
auch so mit so einem Kater.
Ich verrede jetzt aber zum Gatefahren,
nicht zum Rollfeld lang.
Das wäre auch lustig.
Wie wäre es mit beidem?
So direkt zum Flieger, das da abhängt, hinten auf dem Fahrradwerk, am Flugzeug hinten dran.
Da, wo die Fahrräder abhängt.
Das habe ich in Berlin gemacht, auf dem, wie heißt das hier,
dieser alte Flughafen, den sie da rausgemustert haben.
BER. Fast.
Nee, was ist denn das? Nicht Schönefeld, sondern Tegel.
Ja, Tegel haben sie auch.
Es gab noch einen, will ich meinen.
Zumindest da ist ja eigentlich so ein Highlife,
und da ein Fahrrad auf diesen Landebahnen rumzufahren oder auf diesem Rollfeld rumzufahren, ist ziemlich geil.
Das glaube ich gern.
Aber wir waren bei dir. Wie kommt es, dass du für eine schwedische Firma arbeitest?
Das ist eine lustig lange Geschichte. Sie beginnt vor x Jahren.
Am Anfang langweilen.
Die Welt.
Nee, vor x Jahren habe ich mal einen Vortrag gehört bei der Jux Saxony. Es war irgendeine Weihnachtsveranstaltung.
Das ist diese Java-User-Group, oder?
Genau, die Java-User-Group
von Sachsen,
aber meistens sind Sachen in Dresden
oder in Leipzig. Das ist ja Sachsen.
Es gibt nicht mehr Sachsen.
Es gibt so ganz verstreute Chemnitz-Sachen, wo dann immer
niemand hinkommt. Das ist eigentlich fast immer
in Dresden, oder? Kann das sein? Nee, das wäre schön.
Die Sachen, die mich interessieren, sind meistens
irgendwie nie hier. Für die
Weihnachtsveranstaltung habe ich mal Glühwein kochen müssen.
Das kann sein, dass du das
gemacht hast. Ich erinnere mich, dass wir
da im ASCII Glühwein
zu uns genommen haben danach. Auf jeden Fall habe ich
Vortrag gehört von Dirk Mahler.
Der hat ein Tool vorgestellt,
in dem er,
das er so gerade konzeptioniert hatte,
JQ Assistant. Und eigentlich
wollte er darüber reden, aber eigentlich hat er
80% über die Datenbanktechnologie
geredet, die er dahinter verwendet.
Mit dem Namen Neo4j.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen gehuckt.
Dann habe ich irgendwann
später den
Michael Hunger getroffen, auf
lustigerweise einem
von denen, damals als die noch in der
Informatikfakultät waren, dachte ich mir,
ne, hab ich schon mal gehört, das steht an diesem
Stand, du musst sowieso
Belegarbeit, Diplomarbeit schreiben,
machst du mal ein Projekt irgendwie mit denen,
willst du ja irgendwas machen, was irgendwie nicht in eine Schublade
geworfen wird und dann für immer verschwindet.
Und dann hab ich das gemacht.
Nice. Ich glaub,
das Flugzeug draußen ist gerade mit auf dem Band.
So, wer braucht schon
volle Luft?
Ein bekanntes Problem.
Aber es landet doch nicht in Dresden.
Kann ja nicht sein.
Was ist dich neulich an das Grillen?
Wir haben ja letzten Samstag gekriegt,
ein kurzer Temex-Kurs hier an der Elbe.
Und plötzlich fliegt so ein
was privat kleines,
relativ tief
über den Weg.
Das ist aber schon ein bisschen interessant, dass der so lang fliegt.
Dirk hat gleich im Flightrider nachgeschaut,
wo er hin ist, kommt aus Paris zumindest,
wo er gelandet ist.
Richtig eingetragen vor dem Plan?
Doch, also schon was
höherwertiges.
Nicht so eine Chesnau oder so.
Und am nächsten Tag war dann irgendwie Post bei
Dresdner Neue Nachrichten oder in die Radio
Dresdner oder irgendwas auf der Webseite. Von wegen
hier illegal jemand ins Elbteil abgeflogen
und wird gerade ermittelt von
der Flugsicherheit. Wer das war, 30.000 Euro
Strafe und so weiter.
Das war ein teurer Flug.
Da wollte ich bloß mal ein bisschen
hier das Weltkulturerbe angucken.
Ja, wenn du schon keine Drohnen fliegen darfst,
dann wird es wenigstens in Privatscheid ausfliegen dürfen.
Wo ich Drohnen an der Elbe ziemlich häufig sehe,
muss ich sagen.
Das lustig ist, weil das absolut nicht erlaubt ist.
Ja, aber wenn du mal so viel fliegt,
ist Grillen an der Elbe auch nicht?
Es ist in Anführungsstrichen erlaubt.
Es kommt drauf an, wo.
Deswegen haben wir ja auch an der Albert-Brücke
am Grillplatz gegrillt.
Da erinnere ich mich auch dran.
Nee, Neo4j.
Witzigerweise hattest du ja da mal
im FSR den witzigen
Nickname Graf Datenbank.
Ich habe überlegt, mich auf Twitter so zu nennen.
Noch nicht durchgerungen.
Irgendwie bist du da reingerutscht und jetzt bist du da.
Genau, genau.
Graf Datenbank.
Falls irgendein Student
zuhört, es hilft tatsächlich, wenn man
Projekte irgendwo macht, dass man
danach einen Fuß in der Tür hat.
Ich weiß nicht, manche Leute wollen
mir das nicht glauben, aber es hilft wirklich.
weil man dann halt schon mit der
Codebase betraut ist und im Zweifel
auch coole Sachen gemacht hat, die die dann vielleicht
in Zukunft mal einbauen wollen
dann ist man
fängt man da an und ist schon im Prinzip Experte in einem
bestimmten Bereich. Was war das Thema von der Abschlussarbeit?
Weißt du es noch? Weißt du es noch sicherlich
aber kann man das irgendwie sinnvoll erklären
in Audioform?
Das kommt drauf an
Ja, kann man
Vielleicht muss ich vorschieben, dass
Neo4j eine Graph-Date
Was ist eine Graph-Datenbank? Wollen wir so weit ausholen?
Stimmt, das haben wir überhaupt nicht angeschritten, was das überhaupt ist.
Kannst du das irgendwie in drei Minuten erklären?
Bestimmt. Normale Datenbanken sind Tabellen, Spalten, Zeilen, die fest definiert sind, wo man seine Daten reinwirft und die man danach abfragen kann.
Eine Graph-Datenbank geht von diesen Tabellen weg und speichert die Daten in Knoten und Kanten und Properties an diesen Knoten und Kanten.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns ein soziales Netzwerk vorstellen und Tabellen dazu in einem relationalen, in einem normalen Datenbanksystem, dann hast du eine Tabelle mit allen Usern, du hast eine Tabelle, die die Verbindungen zwischen den Usern darstellt und so weiter und die muss man dann zusammenjoinen und das macht nicht so viel Spaß, wer das schon mal gemacht hat.
In einem Graph-System hat man halt einen Knoten, der kann einen User darstellen, der hat irgendwelche Properties, Name, Geschlecht, Anmeldungsdatum, alle möglichen Sachen.
Und der hat zum Beispiel Verbindungen zu anderen Usern, wie der eine User A followt dem anderen.
Da kannst du auch Sachen ranschreiben, wie ab, wann das so ist oder was weiß ich nicht, alle anderen Sachen, die einen interessieren.
Kann man da so ein gewisses Klassenkonzept reinbringen, dass so ein User-Datentyp existiert in Knotenformen oder so?
Wie macht man das?
Das kannst du selber dir definieren, musst aber auch selber darauf aufpassen ein bisschen.
Also Neo4j ist schemafrei, kannst ein paar Sachen definieren.
Kannst du was sagen wie, wenn ich einen Knoten sehe, der User heißt, dann muss der ein Property haben, der Name heißt.
Oder eine interne ID oder irgendwie sowas.
Das kannst du machen. Weitere Sachen kommen irgendwann in Zukunft, nur jetzt gerade noch nicht.
Okay, aber sowas in der Richtung geht schon mal.
Genau, also zweifeln musst du ein bisschen auf dein eigenes Datenmodell aufpassen.
Hat aber den Vorteil, dass du sehr flexible Dinge hinzufügen kannst.
Also du kannst nicht nur deine User in den Dingen haben, du kannst halt, weiß ich nicht, Zahlungsarten mit reinwerfen, du kannst Content-Typen mit reinwerfen.
Ich freue mich auf die ganzen NoSQL-User.
ja, was immer dir einfällt.
Du kannst dein Modell erweitern, wie du möchtest.
Und das Coole ist, dass du zum Zeitpunkt der Abfrage
wirklich nur das anfassen musst.
Also die Datenbank muss im Prinzip nur das wirklich verarbeiten,
was es braucht, um die Anfrage auszuführen.
Das heißt, wenn ich eine Anfrage mache,
wo ich mich für den Freund des Freundes des Freundes interessiere
und ich habe da Zahlungsdaten in dem Graph hängen,
kann ich die wegignorieren.
Das heißt, du musst nicht 35.000 Joints machen?
Richtig.
weil die Joins im Prinzip schon auf Platte liegen.
Das heißt, wir legen die Relationen als Pointer auf der Platte ab.
Und du musst nicht eine ellenlange Tabelle,
die immer weiter größer wird, miteinander joinen
oder 500 Mal ineinander joinen,
was dann irgendwann dazu führt,
dass deine Anfragen ultra langsam sind,
sondern du hast halt wirklich Pointer-Chasing
von Knoten zum nächsten Knoten über die Relationen usw.
Cool.
Du kannst dann halt Graf-Algorithmen draufwerfen
und alles mögliche tolle Sachen machen.
Cool.
Ich habe gehört, das hattest du erzählt, dass diese Panama-Paper aus der Auswertung mit Neo4j gemacht wurde.
Stimmt das?
Genau, genau. Die ICAJ-Leute, die International Consortium of Investigative Journalists, die dieses Leak bearbeitet haben und auch andere danach, haben im Prinzip Neo4j benutzt, nachdem sie die ganzen Daten, die hatten ja mehrere Terabyte an Daten.
Die hatten E-Mails, die hatten eingescannte Dokumente, irgendwelche Bilder von irgendwelchen Personalausweisen und alle möglichen Dinge.
Terabyte davon, die haben die halt digitalisiert, die haben die OCR in irgendeine Form gebracht, wo man halt Daten rauslesen kann.
Und dann haben die das in einen Graph geworfen und haben das gemacht, wofür du eine Graph-Datenbank allgemein verwendest.
du machst Mustersuche darauf.
Das heißt, die wollten zum Beispiel
rausfinden, ob du
irgendwelche Ringe in den Daten siehst.
Ringe im Sinne von,
wo das Geld in dem Ring läuft,
wo es irgendwo anfängt und dann
wenn du wieder eine gleiche Person am besten rausfällst.
Ist das was man macht,
wenn es heißt, die Polizei hat einen Ring
zu schlagen?
Ich hab das eine andere Rede.
Vielleicht. Du könntest das bestimmt so modellieren.
Es gibt mit Sicherheit
auch irgendwo schon Projekte,
wo Leute sowas machen.
Also es ist einfach ein Werkzeug,
was dir erlaubt, Strukturen auf Daten
zu suchen, was eine normale Datenbank
auf die Art und Weise dir nicht so wirklich erlauben würde.
Weil du bei relationalen Systemen immer das Problem
hast, du hast,
du vorher gesagt hast, du musst Tabellen miteinander joinen
und wenn ich jetzt mir
vorstelle, ich habe eine User-Tabelle und ich habe eine
Follow-Tabelle
und ich join die miteinander,
finde ich raus, welcher User mit dem anderen
Follow-Tabelle.
Wenn ich rausfinde, wer den an zweiter Ebene
followed, muss ich nochmal joinen. Das muss ich
aber explizit der Datenbank sagen.
Das heißt, ich kann Sachen wie,
gibt es denn irgendwo einen Ring in den Daten?
Gibt es denn irgendwo,
finde ich irgendwo vielleicht,
weiß ich nicht, über N-Ebenen
einen Weg zurück zum Original-User?
Kann ich nicht rausfinden, weil
ich jedes Mal sagen muss,
explizit join achtmal, join neunmal.
Ich kann nicht sagen, join so oft, bis du
irgendwann was findest. Man muss vor allem
die Struktur immer vorher schon wissen,
gerade für diesen Use-Case.
Im besten Fall, ja, ja, genau.
Wo du einfach erstmal explorativ auf den Daten arbeiten wolltest,
es spielt sich schon an,
es ist irgendwie so unstrukturierter reinzuschmeißen
und dann nachträglich auch diese Grafen,
erst das Kanten anzulegen, die diese Punkte verbinden.
Die wusste du ja wahrscheinlich vorher noch gar nicht.
Cool, genau, genau.
Und die Firma sitzt in Schweden,
weil es eigentlich eine schwedische Firma ist?
Genau, gegründet wurde die in Schweden und wir haben Leute, die in London sitzen, die vier Entwicklungen machen.
Wir haben Leute, die in Malmö sitzen, die vier Entwicklungen machen.
Und weil man ja natürlich so Leute haben muss, haben wir natürlich auch Marketingleute, die in San Mateo sitzen, im Silicon Valley.
Wenn du Leuten was verkaufen möchtest im Silicon Valley, musst du im Silicon Valley sein.
Entwicklung haben wir da aber keine.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten bei euch da generell?
Wir sind jetzt über 200.
Ich frage mich nicht nach der genauen Zahl.
Nee, bist du grob, nein, ohne zu können.
Genau, und dann haben wir halt noch, was auch wichtig ist zu erwähnen,
haben viele, viele verstreute Remote-Leute wie mich.
Also, anders kann ich es nicht sagen.
Zerstreute Remote-Leute.
Zerstreute auf jeden Fall.
Ziemlich verstreuten Eindruck.
Richtig.
Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel vier, fünf Leute schon in Leipzig.
Die hoffen gerne mehr zu werden.
Das heißt, wenn Leute Bock haben, nach Leipzig zu ziehen,
das sind sehr, sehr nette Menschen,
die auf jeden Fall auch noch Leute suchen,
sich für Grafalgorithmen interessiert
und die auf Neo4j bauen möchte,
kann da Kontakte vermitteln.
Okay.
Cool.
Also Leipzig, Dresden, Malmöhe.
Die Achse des Bösen.
Und London,
aber mal gucken, wie wir das sind.
Außerhalb der EU.
Noch.
Bald.
Ich weiß nicht, wann der Podcast kommt.
Für Zögerliebes nach Halloween,
dann war es das.
Die letzten zwei Folgen habe ich so ein bisschen verschleppt.
Dieses Mal hatte ich mir ja nicht vorgenommen, die schneller
rauszuhauen.
Cool.
Was gibt es denn sonst so Neues?
Du bist jetzt
in Lohn und Brot, habe ich gehört.
Genau, ja. Interessantweise arbeiten wir ja
alles, also dein Remote-Arbeitsplatz,
Sascha,
in Betracht gezogen, arbeiten wir alle
in so einem Umkreis von 300 Meter voneinander.
500 Meter, das ist sehr witzig,
finde ich, in der Innenstadt.
Ich habe jetzt auch einen Job, genau, aber da muss man jetzt nicht
groß drauf eingehen. Bloß hat das mit
ÖPNV-Daten zu tun und witziger
Hamburger Firma.
Ich bin quasi auch remote,
aber wir haben ein offizielles Büro in Dresden,
aber das sind halt so 14 Leute.
Du wirst nur 6 anwesend.
Wir nennen das nicht remote.
Das ist nicht remote,
oder? Ihr habt doch da eine eigene
Fläche. Es ist ein Büro, es gehört uns,
aber du bist halt, wenn du,
also der Rest vom Team ist halt nicht in Dresden
und alle Meetings laufen halt über
hier
ab, dementsprechend fühlt es sich
schon sehr remote an.
Nicht so remote wie Sascha,
aber...
Du sitzt den ganzen Tag in so einem Coworking-Space,
oder? Im besten Fall ja.
Also prinzipiell kann ich mich morgens
entscheiden, ob ich in den Coworking-Space fahre
oder ob ich ausschlafe.
Letzteres kann ich nicht auf Dauer
empfehlen, das macht einen kaputt, wenn man die ganze Zeit
zu Hause arbeitet, vor allem wenn man kein explizites
Arbeitszimmer hat.
Aber dass ich in so einen Coworking-Space
gehen, sich da einen Tisch besorgen,
mit fremden
Menschen, die nichts mit dir zu tun haben, Mittagessen
gehen. Das ist ja mit Henrik zusammen, oder?
Ja. Witzig. Was?
Henrik ist doch bei uns das halt eben an.
Genau. Stimmt.
Altbekannter Gast von Akronomie Sieber.
Schöne Grüße an ihn.
Ja, ich hatte mal
überlegt, wie ich das machen würde,
ob ich hier remote
arbeiten könnte oder nicht.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin sehr froh, dass ich
meinen täglichen
Weg ins Büro habe,
vielleicht schon zu Uni-Zeiten ich hingekriegt habe,
von zu Hause irgendwas zu machen, was
nicht irgendwie Freizeitprojekt war.
Und dann brauche ich einfach diesen
harten Schnitt, dass ich jetzt das Haus verlasse
und irgendwo hingehe und von dort aus
die ganze Zeit arbeite.
Es ist schon angenehm, so einen Ort
fest zu verknüpfen mit
produktiver Tätigkeit, das stimmt.
Das sehe ich absolut ein.
Du willst doch einfach deine Wohnung nicht anfangen zu hassen,
weil du den Unterschied nicht mehr siehst.
Ja, vor allem, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dauerhaft produktiv zu Hause zu sein.
Das sind dann so Katzen, die Stress machen oder man lenkt sich dann doch irgendwie mit ab oder keine Ahnung.
Ach, ich müsste diesen Zeppich mal wieder saugen.
Das gefühlt sich dann wie Prüfungszeit an, wo man alles macht, nur nicht lernen.
Ja, genau.
Entsprechend sucht man sich halt einen anderen Ort.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und wie sind Coworking Spaces so?
Unterschiedlich.
Also es gibt da aus jeder Kategorie einen.
Ich war vorher in Impact Loft in Dresden.
Impact Loft?
Ist das im Impact Hub?
Nein.
Das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge.
Das hat mit einer zu tun gehabt.
Ich war nämlich mal in diesem Impact Hub,
weil ich da beim Web-Monthag geredet habe.
Wir haben da sehr viele Veranstaltungen,
Meetups und haste nicht gesehen.
Aber ich war tatsächlich nur
in dem Impact Loft.
Die sitzen in der Nähe
von dem Bürgerbüro in der Altstadt.
Also da, wo eure Firma quasi auch sitzt,
Herr Rick.
Achso, das stimmt.
Deswegen, da waren wir ja Nachbarn zeitweise.
Da sind wir mal zusammen mit der Rissen gegangen.
Genau. Die sind ganz lustig gewesen.
Alles nette Menschen.
Die sind so geführt von einer Firma,
die im Prinzip ein bisschen mehr Platz hatte
und dann einfach andere Leute mit reingeworfen hat.
Die machen ganz coole Sachen.
Die übersetzen
Arztbefunde in Menschen lesbar.
Das habe ich mal gehört.
Genau.
Was habe ich?
Sehr, sehr coole Menschen.
Und so was geht?
Das geht.
Aber es ist doch schon handschriftlich beschriebene Dinge von Ärzten.
Auch.
Nee, genaue Details habe ich auch nicht.
Die beschäftigen Ärzte, die das entziffern.
Genau, und die schulen auch Ärzte,
damit die das krankenkassenmäßig dann irgendwann mal auch...
Und die werten da Daten aus, Gesundheitsbefunde oder was?
Das klingt eigentlich wieder ein bisschen...
Im Prinzip, sie gehen ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung,
wirklich Leute schulen, was andere Ärzte machen sollen,
um Leuten zu erklären, was sie hier hat.
Okay, das klingt ja schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Kranken und so weiter.
Wie gesagt, nette Menschen.
Der Coworking Space war auch ganz cool.
Ein bisschen teuer, muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen.
Also sie hatten ganz coole automatische Schreibtische,
die du runterfahren konntest und
tolles Internet und alles.
Aber tatsächlich,
der Coworking Space, in dem ich jetzt bin, kostet einfach mal die Hälfte.
Das ist ein Argument.
Und das ist der
relativ kleine Coworking Space,
die jetzt in das Student Hotel reingebaut haben, in der ersten Etage.
Das sind effektiv sechs Plätze für Leute, die halt nur einen Schreibtisch wollen
und so kleinere Büros für sechs Leute jeweils auch noch da drin.
Wie stellt man sich sowas generell vor?
Das sind dann halt bunt durcheinander gemischt Leute,
die halt hauptsächlich remote arbeiten, die sich da einmieten.
Genau, lustigerweise, ich glaube, die Leute von dem Student Hotel
erwarten irgendwie
alle möglichen Arten von Business.
Aber tatsächlich alles das Gleiche?
Alles halt Informatiker, Programmierer.
Achso, die erwarten auch, dass da wirklich nichts ist?
Ja, ja, genau.
Den habe ich tatsächlich auch gar nicht gedacht.
Gibt es ja auch, stimmt.
Also man merkt immer die Überraschung,
wenn noch jemand auftaucht,
der auch so sagt,
ich programmiere halt.
Noch so eine.
Genau, genau.
Du wolltest doch endlich mal einen Grafiker hier haben.
Wir haben auch noch einen Platz frei.
Einen von den sechs ist noch eins.
Was für Jobs gibt es noch, wo man
in den Coworking-Space geht?
Du kannst ja prinzipiell vieles remote machen. Ob du das Marketing machst
oder ob du Grafikdesign machst.
Grafiker sind
so eine Gruppe von
Menschen, die so jeden Fall machen.
Nicht nur Software-Opfigler sitzen an einem Schreibtisch.
Ja, aber als Grafiker, da hast du dann wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr Geräte,
die du nicht im Coworking-Space stehen lassen würdest, oder?
Je nachdem.
Wenn ich über den Vergleich noch weitermachen,
das Impact Hub, von dem wir am Anfang geredet haben,
da sind mehr verschiedene Leute.
Also das sind nicht nur IT-Leveler
und die haben auch mehr Platz, also die haben sehr viel Platz
deswegen machen die so viele Veranstaltungen
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das
in Zukunft auch noch mehr wird, weil es mehr Jobs
gibt, die du prinzipiell von zu Hause aus
oder remote machen könntest
und dementsprechend
das noch anwächst
Es gibt auch noch viel, viel mehr Coworking Spaces in
Dresden
Habe jetzt nicht alle ausprobiert
Habe auch neulich einen gefunden, bei dem ich mich mal
umgesehen hatte am Anfang und der schon
zu ist.
Ach, das gibt es nicht mehr oder was?
Ja, bin einfach zufällig vorbeigegangen
und dachte, Moment, das Büro war mal voll.
Ein gemeinsamer Freund von uns
hat jetzt auch neulich,
mit dem habe ich mich neulich gequatscht,
der pendelt die ganze Zeit
in eine andere Stadt,
wo er für seinen Arbeitgeber arbeitet
und ist quasi eine Woche hier und eine Woche dort
und wenn er hier ist,
meint er, dass er einfach ins HQ geht
und dort arbeitet.
Das stelle ich mir ungefähr so,
wie im ASCII arbeiten zu wollen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das geht.
Und er hat dann auch überlegt, eigentlich wäre es ganz cool,
wenn man dem HQ so als Coworking Space
einfach so Geld geben könnte.
So nach dem Motto,
in meinem Coworking Space, wenn ich da hingehe und eine Miete bezahle,
jetzt kann ich von der Steuer absetzen.
Das wäre eigentlich cool,
wenn man das dann einfach so an so einen Verein
wie das HQ weiterleiten könnte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ergiebig
das ist so als Konzept.
Also wenn man die Möglichkeit bekommt, dass man
seinen eigenen Monitor hinstellen kann,
weil du willst ja nicht nur von deinem Notebook arbeiten vielleicht,
und so Dinge.
Vorstellbar, warum nicht?
Das ist halt das, was ich an dem Konzept
eigenes Büro mag.
Ich gehe halt an meinen Arbeitsplatz
und da liegt halt mein Zeug auf meinem Schreibtisch
und da kann ich mir meinen Monitor so einstellen lassen,
wie er war. Das ist dein Wohnzimmer, wo du dich einrichten kannst.
Ja, das ist genauso der einzige
Grund, warum ich ein eigenes Auto
haben wollen würde, anstatt mir ständig
irgendwo eins zu leiden ist, dass ich meinen Scheiß drin liegen lassen kann.
Aber da hast du ja das
große Glück, dass es so viele
Spaces gibt, kannst du halt den aussuchen,
wo du das trotzdem haben kannst.
Also an unserem hat jeder einen eigenen Platz
und hat sich jeder im Prinzip einen eigenen Monitor hingestellt,
noch zusätzlich, oder
seine eigene Tastatur noch daneben gelegt.
Na gut, okay.
Der bringt dann jeden Morgen sein Notebook mit und wirft das dann nur ran.
Hendrik ist ein Büromessi,
halten wir das fest.
Du solltest ihn bei den Schreibtisch der anderen sehen.
Ah, okay.
Der Schreibtisch der anderen.
Sendungstitelsammlung?
Schreibtisch der anderen.
Genau, und vielleicht
könnte man noch sagen, eine wichtige Dinge
für so ein Coworking-Space, mein größter
Tipp ever, Noise-Canceling-Headphones.
Oh, das gilt glaube ich
für alle Büros, oder?
Kann sein, da aber besonders,
vor allem, wenn es auf der Prager Straße ist.
Oh ja, hast du ein Fenster zu
Eikos-Mail-Elefone?
Ihr habt ja keine Ahnung, wie
viele sehr, sehr bescheiden
Ich habe meinen Freund aus dem Mal besucht, der bei LaVou gearbeitet hat.
Die haben auch Fenster davor.
Wir haben ja praktischerweise nur Fenster zum Innenhof von dem Gebäude
und da hörst du nicht mehr, die vorne sind.
Ich muss sagen, John Lennon leidet nach seinem Tod immer noch sehr an den Leuten,
die ihn versuchen, musikalisch darzustellen auf der Prager.
Schwerst du dich also, dass die Straßenmusiker für deinen Arbeitsalltag zu untalentiert sind?
Ja.
Das ist immer diese eine Familie, die er immer gesungen hat.
Das war schrecklich.
Hat sogar genervt, wenn du da halt einkaufen gegangen.
Die kenn ich jetzt nicht. Das waren so eine sechsköpfige
Familie, die laut schreien da irgendwie.
Die waren zumindest
mit vollem Elan bei der Sache.
Das schon, aber die haben, also das
klingt cool, wenn du einmal vorbeigehst, aber wenn du
das vierte Mal vorbeigehst, dann wird es schon nervig.
Und wenn du da halt arbeitest und stundenlang
das hörst du nicht auf, dann gehst du dabei ein.
Das Blöde bei Noise-Kennzeln-Kopfhörern
bei dem Problem ist halt, wenn du
dabei in einem Meeting bist oder du machst
Pair-Programming.
Und dein Gegenüber, mit dem du gerade redest, fragt dich, was da gerade im Hintergrund gesungen wird.
Du hörst es nicht, aber dein Mikro ist halt offen.
Wie nervig ist das, wenn andere Leute im Meeting sind dort?
Meistens bin ich der, der quatscht, weil wir halt sehr viel Pair-Programming machen.
Aber es gibt Möglichkeiten, woanders hinzugehen.
Also die haben da auch irgendwie so extra Räume für?
Es gibt so einen kleinen Telefonraum, in dem man aber nicht sein möchte, weil der viel zu klein ist.
Das nennt sich bei uns Huddle Rooms.
Und ansonsten gibt es so Meetingräume, die man rein kann, die fast nie ausgenutzt sind.
Wenn man will, kann man da weg.
Okay. Mal schauen.
Wir haben auch solche extra Meetingräume, aber bisher waren alle Meetings, die ich habe, mit meinem Büropartner zusammen.
Beziehungsweise ist der jetzt im Urlaub, also sitze ich hier alleine gerade da.
aber deswegen ist es kein Problem.
Und wie viel Paarst du da bis jetzt?
Wie viel Paar, was?
Wie viel Paar programmst du? Achso, gar nicht.
Gar nicht. Nee, sowas machen wir nicht.
Zeitverschwendung
macht das mal nicht.
Ich weiß nicht,
meine persönliche Präferenz ist es auch nicht, aber ich habe, wie gesagt,
sehr wenig bisher gemacht. Also vielleicht ist es ja ganz witzig,
aber das ist nicht so mein Ding.
Glaube ich zumindest. Das kann cool sein.
Das kommt doch darauf an, in was du dich einarbeitest
und so weiter.
Dann ja, klar.
vielleicht, wenn du mir wirst, das kann ich dir einen Eindruck geben,
was man halt zum Beispiel wunderbar machen kann,
vor allem, wenn man nicht nebeneinander sitzt
und so Screensharing-Software benutzt oder so.
Was wir zum Beispiel manchmal machen,
ist, dass Person A fängt an, einen Test zu schreiben
für irgendein neues Feature.
Witzige Ideen.
Person B muss danach, wenn der Test fertig ist,
machen das.
Das heißt, danach gleichzeitig.
Nein, nein, nicht gleichzeitig.
Aber es geht immer nur um so ganz kleine Iterationen.
Also macht die Two-Person-TDD oder was?
Ja, genau. Und du musst im Prinzip immer
entweder versuchen, dass der Test grün wird
oder einen Test schreiben, der halt nicht grün wird.
Das ist ja auch so witzig, ich kratze mausmäßig vor
von Dingen, jetzt mache ich den Test aber so, dass er
deinen Code verkackt, haha. Aber er testet ja
immer noch sinnvolle Dinge.
Ja, solange du sinnvolle Sachen machst, ist das alles erlaubt.
Du schreibst am Ende bessere Tests dadurch.
Das ist witzig.
Wie macht ihr das? Checkt ihr dann zwischendurch ein?
Und ich meine, ihr sitzt ja wirklich nicht am selben Rechner.
Genau, es gibt genug Software, bei denen du
einfach Kontrolle über deinen Rechner
zum Beispiel einfach freigeben kannst.
Früher konnte das Slack,
früher war vor einem Monat
oder so, das haben die jetzt
gekillt, jetzt gibt es nur noch Screensharing
und du kannst beim anderen noch auf dem Bildschirm rummalen,
aber das war es jetzt.
Du hattest diese VS Code Plugin ausprobiert?
Wir haben eine Menge Dinge ausprobiert,
aber das glaube ich noch nicht.
Es liegt aber daran, dass wir mit IntelliJ4 arbeiten.
Ah, okay.
Ich persönlich brauche gerade
was Neues,
aber man könnte auch
sowas machen, dass halt einfach mal kurz
pushen und dann wieder
der andere übernimmt dann halt Screen Sharing
kurz.
Also bei uns
heißt es dann wirklich, einer ist
Driver und der andere ist
der Beifahrer.
Der eine
schaut zu, der andere kommentiert
und denkt mit und dann, sobald du
irgendwie ein paar Schritte gemacht hast,
wechselst du. Das machen wir auch
nicht immer so gründlich, weil
häufig der eine mehr vorausgedacht
hat als der andere und das Konzept schon
vor allem, wenn du unterschiedliche Ahnungen
von der Codebase hast, da weiß der
eine schon relativ genau,
was zu machen ist und der andere macht hauptsächlich mit,
damit er das Wissen mit abfangen kann.
Genau dafür ist Pair Programming
halt super gedacht. Also wir spielen
dieses Spiel jetzt auch nicht sehr oft,
halt immer, wann es sich anbietet.
Es gibt Sachen, wo du halt auch nicht
erstmal keine Tests schreibst, erstmal rum
explorierst, mal gucken, wo du gerade bist
und ob du irgendwie einen Spike entbauen kannst,
der überhaupt funktioniert.
Aber im besten Fall
schreibt halt Tests und
baust dein Feature und so weiter, iterativ.
Auch ein Vorteil, wenn man
remote arbeitet, man ist
nicht so sehr
von der Grippewelle
des anderen überrannt.
Weil einfach eine physische Barriere davor ist.
Noch.
Ich bin zu tief im Cyberspace-Leben.
Oh Gott, wenn wir das übertragen können,
oh mein Gott. Ich glaube ja eigentlich nicht, dass Schweden
Grippen kriegen können, oder?
Kalt wird's da auch, du.
Ja, die sind ja nicht alle extrem abgehärtet dann dementsprechend?
Wenn das nur korrelieren würde.
Ich weiß nicht, was Lakritze zu deinem Immunsystem anrichtet.
Wenn das ist, dann sollte ich vielleicht doch noch überlegen,
was Zeug zu essen.
Tu es, lecker, lecker.
Ja, und wie ist es in Malmö?
Malmö ist sehr, sehr schön.
Im Winter weniger als im Sommer überraschenderweise.
Ich glaube, die ganzen Schweden meinen alle, dass Schweden im Winter einfach nicht schön ist, weil es zu kalt und zu dunkel ist.
Kommt ja darauf an, wo in Schweden du bist.
Wenn du in Malmö bist, ist es nicht so, dass du keine Sonne mehr siehst im Winter.
Du bist noch weit genug im Süden.
Hier steht im Juli maximal 21 Grad.
Naja, nicht ganz.
Wikipedia lügt nicht.
Ich kann dir sagen, dass das ein bisschen höher war die zwei Wochen, wo ich da war im Juli.
Ich glaube es dir.
Aber es war schön, die Hitzewelle, die ihr hier hattet, in Schneeben zu sein.
Vor allem Malmö liegt halt direkt am Öresund.
Das heißt, du hast sehr viel Wasser, du hast sehr viel Wind.
Selbst wenn es da ultra heiß ist, hast du Wind.
Das ist ein Vorteil, den du hier nicht hast.
Und ein Nachteil im Winter, wenn der Wind den Schnee quasi dir so sehr ins Gesicht bläst,
dass du kaum vorwärts laufen kannst.
Das kommt auch mal vor.
Aber im Sommer, wunderschöner.
Die Stadt ist nicht ansatzweise so groß wie Dresden.
Ich würde sagen, 300.000 Einwohner steht hier.
Das ist schon 60%.
Die Hipsterquote ist ein bisschen höher als Dresden, würde ich sagen.
Wenn du Lust hast, kannst du dich in die Bahn setzen,
fährst über die Brücke und bis in Kopenhagen.
Das heißt, großer Vorort quasi von Kopenhagen, wenn man so will.
Ist ja witzig, das so zu sehen.
Ich darf den Schweden nicht sagen.
Fahren manchmal Leute mit dem Fahrrad?
Ich würde so gerne mit dem Fahrrad über diese Brücke fahren.
Aber ich bin einmal mit dem Doppelstockbus rüber.
Hat sie einen Radweg?
Nee, du darfst das nicht.
Achso, weil die ab der Hälfte ein Tunnel wird, ne?
Nicht ganz auf der Hälfte, aber also, ja, ja, A, das.
Mit dem Fahrrad möchte ich nicht durch den Tunnel fahren.
Und B, da ist echt Hartwind oben.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin einmal mit dem Doppelstockbus, saß oben
und hatte doch schon auch Respekt dafür,
dass der Bus immer weiter so gegen den Rand gedrückt wurde.
Alle anderen waren so komplett entspannt.
Nur irgendwie hat es mich verunsichert.
Lukas, Patrick und ich
hatten mit anderen Autos nicht
rübergetraut damals. Das war schon so.
Das macht die Lenkung doch nicht mit.
Das fühlt sich dann an,
als ob man auf dem Schiff ist oder was?
Das Auto so kränkt.
Das Auto hat ja generell Probleme gehabt.
Das Auto war prima, um vom A nach B zu kommen,
solange du beim B auch geschlafen hast.
Du konntest genau einmal am Tag anmachen,
das Auto, oder anlassen.
Danach musstest du ungefähr in der Nacht warten,
bis es am 20. Mal anging.
was superkacke war, das eine Mal, wo Lukas das mitten
in den Ohrenlisse abgewürgt hat, an der Ampel,
an der Kreuzung, die
gut befahrene, dreispurige Straße war,
wo dann Baustelle auf eine Spur runtergeprägt
war. Wir standen vorne an der Ampel.
Dann steigen die Deutschen erstmal aus und schieben das Auto
über die Kreuz. Und dann habt ihr
da übernachtet. Und dann haben wir ein paar Stunden
in den Ohrenlisse verbraucht. In Kostel, da ging er irgendwann
spätabends nochmal an.
Jetzt will das jetzt debacken.
Was ist in diesem Motor passiert,
dass du den nur einmal am Tag anmachen kannst?
Der startet er nicht mehr. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da schief ging, aber der startete
stundenlang nicht mehr, nachdem er einmal lief.
Hat besonders ein bisschen was Hitze-bedingtes.
Ich kenne mich eh nicht aus, aber...
Du musst wahrscheinlich abkühlen, das kann sein.
Das Auto war sehr witzig.
Ich dachte, dass wir ein paar Sachen in dem Auto gefunden haben
noch und Angst hatten, dass wir an der Grenze irgendwie...
Wenn ihr das jetzt hört und euch irgendwie mit
Kfz-Technik so ein bisschen auskennt,
dann erklärt uns doch mal bitte, warum ein Auto
potenziell nach... Ein alter VW-Bus.
Ein alter VW-Bus nur einmal am Tag
abgelassen werden kann und danach
nicht mehr startet.
Aber na gut, okay, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen. Eigentlich wollten wir so ein bisschen über Malmö reden. Naja, nicht unbedingt, aber so allgemein deine etwas witzige Situation, dass du hier als Einziger, und das ist ja bei Henrik von Mozilla, der hier auch schon zu Gast war, ist es ja auch so. Er ist der einzige Mitarbeiter seiner Firma in Dresden und arbeitet zwangsweise remote und von einem Coworking-Space aus.
und das ist ja schon eine ziemlich spannende Situation.
Du hattest nicht unbedingt überlegt, mal nach Malmöhe zu ziehen oder zumindest Leipzig oder so?
Überlegt habe ich, wenn man das so überschlägt, würde ich natürlich eine Menge Wochenenden mehr sparen,
die ich reise und generell viel Aufwand.
Von daher, die Überlegung ist auf jeden Fall da.
Aber aus diversen Gründen habe ich mich dazu entschieden, erstmal von hier zu arbeiten
und mal gucken, wie es sich hier weiterentwickelt,
ob man noch weiter in Sachsen wohnen möchte,
ab September oder nicht,
kann man sich ja immer noch umentscheiden.
Das stimmt.
Und es ist hilfreich, wenn man zufällig noch einen Plan B in Schweden hat.
Das war ja bei dem anderen Kollegen,
den ich jetzt nicht erwähne,
auch so, der einmal die Woche irgendwie
nach Westdeutschland pendelt
und eine Woche hier und eine Woche da arbeitet,
wo ich mich dann echt frage,
ist es krass, dass der,
und der fliegt auch,
Die fliegt also quasi montags darüber und kommt freitags zurück und wohnt zwischendurch in einem Hotel.
Das macht ja den Arbeitnehmer für den Arbeitgeber nicht unbedingt billiger, wenn er die ganze Zeit so hin und her reist.
Dass die sich das trotzdem an die Backe binden, sich so einen teuren Mitarbeiter anzustellen.
Ja, das Ding ist halt, Remote-Arbeiten ist so ein bisschen die Notlösung.
Aber gerade in der IT, wo wir nicht genug Leute haben,
hast du irgendwann einfach die Situation, dass du, wenn du gute Leute willst,
musst du sowas anbieten.
Unsere Firma war immer schon ein bisschen verteilt.
Das heißt, wir sind halt prädestiniert dafür.
Das funktioniert von der Kultur her auch ganz gut.
Aber ich sage jetzt mal, Lund University wirft nicht genug Absolventen ab,
die wir einstellen könnten.
Du musst einfach auch woanders suchen.
Und nicht jeder kann nach Malmö ziehen
oder will das.
Und du willst sie trotzdem einstellen,
wenn sie vielleicht gut sind.
Wir haben eine Menge Leute.
Jetzt schon dritten Praktikanten
aus den Niederlanden zum Beispiel.
Das sind wunderbare Leute,
die ich alle ein bisschen nach Malmö ziehen
wollen würde.
Aber kann halt auch nicht.
Jeder war ja privat in einer Situation,
wo er noch nicht dahin ziehen kann
oder so weiter und so fort.
die ganz Neuen willst du nicht
Remote anstellen, oder?
Das ist auch so eine Sache, wenn du gerade von der Uni fällst,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass du direkt erstmal Remote
anfangen kannst, du bist
gewissermaßen benachteiligt.
Vor allem, wenn du nicht viel Pre-Programming machst,
nicht so viel
One-to-One hast mit den Menschen,
die dir halt Sachen beibringen können,
hast du Nachteile und die musst du versuchen,
selber auszugleichen.
Du kriegst Hilfe von den Menschen, wenn du
danach fragst oder wenn sie nett sind,
dann gehen sie so auf dich ein, ohne dass du fragen musst,
aber prinzipiell
muss man wissen, dass man da benachteiligt
ist in dem Sinne.
Das ist halt bei jedem Job auch so, aber
wenn derjenige halt eh bei dir mit im Büro
sitzt, kannst du halt immer mal so
casually
dran vorbeilaufen und sagen, na, wie steht's?
Also was, was du wahrscheinlich aus den Augen
verlierst, wenn derjenige die ganze Zeit
bloß irgendwie hinter so einem
Chat-Tool sitzt oder hinter einem Slack sitzt.
Auf jeden Fall und du verlierst auch diese ganzen
das ganze Menschliche dahinter.
Du willst ja mit deinen Kollegen auch irgendwie Spaß haben.
Du willst ja ein cooles Klima in der Firma haben.
Und das ist auch einer der großen Gründe, warum ich halt da ständig bin.
Dass man auch mit den Kollegen heute mal was unternehmen kann.
Wir haben jetzt neulich angefangen,
donnerstags um eins,
alle paar Wochen spielen wir jetzt ein großes Mario Kart-Konier.
Alle Leute, die eine Switch haben,
wählen sich da ein und dann...
Das finde ich großartig.
Macht mein Kollege Simon alle fertig.
oder ich, wenn ich großes Glück habe.
Das ist groß, also
sowas kannst du halt auch Remote-Leute erreichen
und es lohnt sich
halt auch zu machen. Allein dieses
zusammen mit der Ressen, das ist auch irgendwie so,
das schweißt einfach so ein Team zu schwierig.
Genau, deswegen musst du halt manchmal da sein,
um sowas auch zu machen
und mal entspannt über Probleme zu
reden oder auch nicht über Arbeit
reden, das ist auch manchmal ganz
sinnvoll.
Das nächste Mal fliege ich nicht,
Also man nehme die Bahn.
Wir stehen elf Stunden bevor.
Mit viermal umsteigen.
Warum machst du sowas?
Weil ich mich schlecht fühle,
die ganze Zeit zu fliegen.
Ja gut, okay.
Und tatsächlich, wenn du früh genug buchst,
kannst du es auch billiger hinkriegen.
Wie früh genug musst du damit buchen?
Also ich hatte jetzt zum Spaß mal für Oktober geguckt zum Beispiel.
Schaffst du es für 60 Euro dahin.
Und krass.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich erstaunlich
günstig, aber wenn du jetzt einen Monat vorher
60 Euro nach Malmö mit der Bahn.
Und da kannst du noch den 25er
Bahncard-Rabatt runterrechnen.
Der fuck? Ich habe letztens mit Johannes
zusammen von dem Parken DD Projekt Tickets
nach Basel gekauft, weil wir da
auf einen Open Data Mieter beingeladen worden sind
von den Leuten.
Und haben halt
Bahntickets geschaut und Johannes wollte
unbedingt die erste Klasse fahren und das machte
preislich überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Das waren so
20 Euro oder so. Und bei der ersten Klasse
ist die Sitzpass-Reservierung auch dabei, sprich
die du eh machen wolltest.
Die du eh auf die Strecke machst sowieso.
Demnach hat sich das Preis sich wirklich eigentlich
nicht gegeben, aber das war hin und zurück für zwei Personen
das erste Mal, dass ich auf der Bahnseite
einen vierstelligen Preis gesehen habe.
1050 Euro
Flexpreis haben wir natürlich nicht genommen, aber what
the fuck. In welchem Zeitraum?
Also wann wäre das gewesen?
Im Ende September jetzt dann.
Okay, okay.
Das ist nicht die drei Monate vorher,
die du normal... Aber holy shit!
Das ist mein Preis.
krass. Der eine fährt nach Malmö für
60 Euro und der andere nach Basel
für 1000 Euro. Also wir haben natürlich
nicht die Flexpreis-Tickets genommen.
Wir haben insgesamt nur 200 noch was gezahlt,
aber trotzdem. Also realistischer
ist auch 200 die Ecke.
Meine nächste Sache kostet
150 hin und zurück.
Aber das ist doch mit dem Flug da gar nicht so anders, oder?
Der Flug muss doch auch irgendwas in den Drehsammeln.
Du findest günstige Flüge für den
Preis, wenn du ganz viel Glück hast, aber so im
Schnitt waren meine immer so 220.
Okay, sowas hätte ich auch erwartet.
In der Dreh.
Das kriegst du aber trotzdem Expensed.
Ja, ja, das Zeitung kriegt die schon mal.
Das wäre ja hart, wenn wir schon einmal im Monat hin.
Bei uns ist es auch so, wir machen manchmal...
Die Bahntickets buche ich selber tatsächlich.
Die muss ich dann halt im Nachhinein mit zurückholen.
Ja, aber das geht auch hoffentlich, weil sonst wäre das ja absurd.
Ja, ja, klar, ich sag mal.
Bei uns ist es so, dass wir
manchmal Dienstreisen nach Karlsruhe machen
und da heißt es auch schon so,
ab einer Bahnfahrt von fünf Stunden
darfst du erste Klasse buchen.
und das letzte Mal war es so spontan,
dass wir allerdings irgendwie, da sind wir
irgendwie zu acht oder so mit der Bahn
runtergefahren, wir haben einfach keine Plätze mehr zusammen
gekriegt.
Da saßen wir aber die ganze Zeit einfach in dem
Speisewagen,
eine Tasse Kaffee jeder bestellt und sehr langsam getrunken
und dann konnten wir da auch mal zusammensetzen.
Das ist einer der wenigen Vorteile,
wenn du ständig fliegst.
Die verdammten Lufthansa-Business-Lounges.
Ich meine,
Dekadenz lässt grüßen.
Das Land, wo Milch und Honig und sehr viel Alkohol fließen.
Dieser elitäre Club, wie man sich so vorstellt.
Ein bisschen. Und das Schönste ist,
dass ich jedes Mal Fehlernplatz aussehe.
Ich meine, es gibt da Leute,
die keinen anzutragen.
Und dann gibt es mich.
Ich habe schon überlegt,
ob sie mich mit einer Jogginghose reinlassen.
Ist aber jetzt noch nicht mein Stil.
Vielleicht eines Tages mal gucken.
Ja, ich gehe einer
regulären Tätigkeit nach.
Ja, ich verdiene mein eigenes Geld.
Nein, ich wohne nicht mehr bei Mutti.
Ja, ich kann mir diesen Flug leisten.
Ja, ja, cool.
Aber ich finde es völlig voll in Ordnung,
dass du mal nicht fliegst,
sondern das auf dich nimmst.
Vor allem, weil du ja,
11 Stunden ist wirklich lange.
Nimmst du da schon,
machst du da quasi schon,
das ist ja quasi ein ganzer Arbeitstag.
Das kannst du ja auch nicht als Freizeit irgendwie nehmen.
Das ist ja wirklich noch ein Arbeitstag mehr, der weg ist.
Ich kann mir fast vorstellen, dass dein Arbeitgeber sagt,
nee, flieg du mal bitte,
weil ich dann weniger Arbeitszeit verliere.
oder sowas, aber so musst du ja quasi
sagen, da muss ich tatsächlich im Zug arbeiten, damit die
Zeit sich auch lohnt. Die Ansage habe ich zumindest noch nicht gekriegt,
aber du hast, da ist was dran.
Man muss dazu sagen, wenn
ich jetzt von Tür zu Tür
mit dem Flug und mit
einer günstigen Umsteigezeit
und... Du kannst ja sagen, mit dem Flug hast du ja noch ein bisschen
Wartest du im Flughafen oder so mit drauf? Ja, ja klar, du willst
ja nicht kurz vor knapp ankommen. Wenn du das
machst, läuft irgendwas schief und dann, naja.
Und wenn nichts ausfällt
zwischendurch, hatte ich auch schon ein paar Mal, das ist
total der Spaß.
dann dauert das trotzdem
neun bis
Plusstunden
von meiner Haustür
bis zum Hotel in Malmö.
Also das hatte ich mal durchgerechnet für unsere
Karlsruhe-Reisen, da gibt es auch Leute, da gibt es halt
drei Optionen, Auto, Zug oder Flugzeug
und
Auto kannst du machen, wenn du unbedingt
willst.
Der Unterschied ist
jeweils plus minus bloß eine Stunde.
Also wenn du fliegst, bist du
nur eine Stunde schneller, weil du bis nach
Frankfurt höchstens fliegst und dann mit irgendwas
anderem weiter musst, also dann nochmal Auto mieten
oder doch Bahn fahren.
Kann man selber fliegen machen?
Ist das eine Option?
Ich würde gerne selber Bahn fahren.
Und das hatte ich einmal,
dass einer bestanden hat darauf, dass wir fliegen
und wir haben zwar
nicht sechs, sondern fünf Stunden gebraucht, aber du bist
die ganze Zeit beschäftigt und musst dann nochmal
durch zwei Security-Checks an den neuen Schlangen anstehen
und dann nach dem Leihwagen anstehen
Das nächste Mal machen wir das nicht nochmal.
Dann kommt der eine Kollege, der den Jakobsweg entlang wandert
und drei Tage später ankommt.
Geht der an den Palswurzerei?
Und hat der auch eine Security-Check-Schlange,
das ist auch die Frage.
Ich würde ja mit dem Fahrrad...
Oh, das ist aber auch geil.
Das sind was, 800 Kilometer oder 600 Kilometer?
Ja, aber Zug nach Maimil musst du dann nicht auch
mit dem ICE, der auf der Fähre gepackt wird?
Mit mehrere?
Zug auf der Fähre.
Ich glaube, ich nehme den, ja.
Ich habe das Person im Kopf von Sebastian, der mal einen Flieger aus Kopenhagen
genommen hatte und mit dem ICE dahin gefahren
ist und auch plötzlich saß er im Zug
auf einer Fähre. Der Zug war komplett
aus und dann kamen Leute durch,
die haben seinen Pass sehen wollen. Das war
eine coole Erfahrung,
habe ich auch noch nicht gemacht. Die Passsache ist auch
verrückt. Also du hast, wenn du nach
Schweden fährst, von Kopenhagen
aus, hast du halt
eine 1-3-Chance,
dass die Polizei einmal durchgeht und sagt,
ich möchte mal bitte die Ausweise von allen sehen.
Also trotzdem Schengen-Raum, oder? Ja, ja, klar.
Aber trotzdem wollen wir natürlich die Ausweise sehen manchmal.
Dänemark macht das zur Grenze von Deutschland auch,
offensichtlich, manchmal, wenn sie lustig sind.
Finde ich schrecklich.
Absolut.
Muss alles nicht sein.
Ja, lass uns nicht über dieses Thema reden.
Das wird bloß zu düster.
Und in Malmö bewegst du dich aber,
wenn du dann einmal in Malmö angekommen bist,
was machst du dann?
Wie kommst du vom Flughafen?
Oder hast du irgendwie regelmäßig dasselbe Hotel,
was sich irgendwie in der Nähe vom Arbeitsorten befindet.
Es gibt dort zwei Hotels,
wo sie uns unterbringen.
Das eine Hotel ist
fünf Minuten zu Fuß vom Hauptbahnhof entfernt.
Und
der Ort, wo ich dann da arbeite,
ist sieben Minuten von diesem Ort entfernt.
Das heißt,
alles fußläufig.
Das andere Hotel ist lustigerweise
das gleiche Gebäude wie unsere Firma.
Das heißt, wenn du da
untergebracht wirst, kannst du quasi
morgens zum Mittag in den...
nach oben fahren, auf der Dachterrasse
Frühstück essen und dann fährst du runter in die
Firma und hast das Gebäude
quasi nicht verlassen.
Kann ich nicht unbedingt empfehlen, weil man
diesen Drang hat, rauszugehen.
Das Gebäude mal zu verlassen.
Du musst vor allem aufpassen, dass du nicht aus Versehen
irgendwie einen Badelatschen und Schlappen und
einen Quartier Schlafanzug
ins Büro gehst.
Das ist noch nicht passiert, aber ja, vielleicht.
Aber
deinen Roller nimmst du nicht mit nach meinem Mühe, oder?
Nee.
Die gibt es da auch schon.
So Leihroller, die haben da angefangen
im Januar oder sowas auszukippen,
die ersten Limes.
Seitdem fahre ich die da auch,
sehr exzessiv. Ich meine, die haben die Infrastruktur
dafür. Deren Fahrradwege sind
halt wunderbar.
Dort fährt man auch auf Fahrradwegen, oder?
Ja, Fahrradwege. Und wenn keiner da ist, dann Straße.
Aber du hast halt
sehr viele Fahrradwege. Die sind ultrabreit.
Die ziehen sich durch die
komplette Stadt. Die sind ausgeschildert.
Das sind eigene Schilder, wo du in welchen Stadtteil
willst damit. Das ist echt cool. Das ist nice.
Das ist richtig, richtig,
richtig gut durchdacht. Und wie reagieren die
Fahrradfahrer dort auf die Roller?
Normal.
Also, jetzt nicht so ein Krieg
wie hier. Und vor allem die
Historie ist nicht so hoch.
Es geht gerade richtig hoch von irgendwie
diversen Verbänden, die fordern, dass das wieder zurückgeht.
Das war ja vorher schon der Fall. Bevor irgendwas
passiert ist, hieß es ja schon, hier würde Mord
und Totschlag passieren. Und die Zahlen, die
jetzt raus sind, supporten
das so überhaupt nicht. Es gibt halt
die Roller sind nicht das Problem, ist aber nur ehrlich
die Menschen, die die benutzen, sind das Problem
wenn du die Dinger halt
beschissen abstellst
das ist dasselbe Problem, was die Leute mit den
Leihfahrrädern haben, mit den X-Bikes und so weiter
also ich sehe diese Lime
Lime
die stehen jetzt hier bei uns auch
ziemlich häufig rum, ich habe auch schon ein paar
wild rumstehen sehen, wo sie wahrscheinlich nicht gehört haben
das ist ja letzte Woche gestartet, oder?
letzte Woche, letzte Woche
Donnerstag, genau
es gibt seit knapp zwei Wochen hier in der Stadt, genau
und ich glaube, das Hauptproblem war eher
oder der Hauptdiskussionspunkt war hauptsächlich,
dass dann die
paar Politiker versucht haben, cool zu sein
und gesagt haben, wir unterstützen das voll, dass
die Leute jetzt alle mehr Roller fahren
und die Radfahrverbände
haben hauptsächlich erstmal gesagt, sorg du mal bitte
erstmal dafür, dass wir überhaupt eine steigende
Fahrradinfrastruktur haben. In Schweden ist es
halt so, da gibt es diese Infrastruktur schon
und da ist es gut und hier
bist du mit dem Roller,
haben sie wahrscheinlich genauso oder noch mehr
aufgeschmissen eigentlich erst mit dem Fahrrad.
Wenn du mit dem Fahrrad mal hart bremsen musst, dann
musst du halt mal hart bremsen, aber mit dem Roller
da fliegst du halt
komplett über. Also da muss wirklich auch
ein sicherer Straßenverkehr
für solche
Personen gewährleistet sein und das ist halt nicht
wirklich der Fall. Wir können gleich mal anfangen, Autos zu verbieten,
Fahrradwege auszubauen, wir Spuren übernehmen
und... Habt ihr diese
Aufnahmen
aus Berlin gesehen, wo jetzt diese
Lieblingsregen-Geschichte war? Also in Berlin
hat es geschüttet wie Sau und es gab so ein paar schöne Videos,
wo du dir gedacht hast, ach Berlin,
einmal diese Gruppe von
drei, vier Typen, die am Bordstein sitzen
in Badeklamotten und mit den Füßen
im Wasser und dann kommt der
Bus vorbeigefahren und spritzt die Nass und die so
und das andere
war halt dieser Radweg, wo sich die Farbe gelöst hat
und es wurde dann breit geschmiert
und plötzlich war der irgendwie dreispurig.
Was haben die da für Aquarell, um irgendwie
die Straßen zu machen?
Oft haben sie sich gedacht, der Radweg bleibt hier
wahrscheinlich eh nicht lange oder sowas.
Das Gefühl ist krass.
Es gab da vor
vielleicht einem Monat oder sowas,
gab es einen schönen,
das war der ADFC in Köln,
der den Menschen, der die
Radwege in Kopenhagen gebaut hat
oder geplant hat, die haben ihn
eingeladen und sind mit dem ein bisschen durch die Stadt
gefahren und haben im Prinzip nur eine Kamera
auf ihn gehalten, während er quasi einen Herzanfall gekriegt hat
ständig.
Hab dann vorgeschlagen, ob man daraus
nicht eine Sendung machen kann, also jede durch die Stadt
mal kurz touren kann mit ihm.
Das ist witzig.
Quintessenz war halt, wenn ich das so
bauen würde, würde man mich feuern dafür.
Und das ist halt wirklich
der Fall.
So ein kaputtes Autoland hier.
Obwohl, ich meine, an ein paar
Stellen denkst du dir, naja,
damit bin ich, also sehr gut,
dass ihr das jetzt gemacht habt.
Die Strecke vom Hauptbahnhof hoch
zur
Carola-Brücke.
Ist es Marien oder Carola-Brücke?
Carola-Brücke, da.
die St. Petersburger Straße lang, da haben sie jetzt
komplett die Autofarkplätze weggenommen.
Gott sei Dank.
Das war fucking beäxtigend, da lang zu fahren.
Du musst ja in jedes Auto reinschauen, ob da jemand drin ist, der gleich die Tür
aufreißt. Genau. Und ab dem Moment,
wo du das siehst, ist auch schon zu spät.
Seien wir ehrlich. Das war einfach
ultra gefährlich. Vor allem,
was da immer mehr auffällt,
ich habe das im Tweet mal vor einer Weile gelesen, aber wenn man
darauf achtet, wie viel öffentlicher Raum
einfach flöten geht für Autos, die da
sinnlos rumstehen. Und Autos stehen
ja immer rum, die sind ja nicht irgendwo anders,
sondern die stehen immer irgendwo rum.
Das ist einfach fest verplanter öffentlicher Raum.
Tausende von Quadratkilometern, die komplett unbenutzbar sind.
Vielleicht kann ich euch doch ein Bild mal nachher zeigen.
Hatte ich jetzt letztes Mal gesehen,
es war ein Fahrradaufsteller,
der im Prinzip die Form eines Autos hatte,
nur konntest du halt Fahrräder an die andere Seite hängen.
Ah ja, das kenne ich.
Da kannst du irgendwie acht Fahrräder oder so ranstellen.
Großartig.
Das gibt es manchmal,
wo sie auf Autoparkplätzen dann so große Müllcontainer hinstellen.
die Mühecontainer sind bloß Attrappen, wo du dann deinen Fahrrad
reinstellen kannst oder sowas.
Sehr schön. Solche Hacks brauchen wir mehr.
Ja, bin ich dafür.
Ich meine, du kannst ja theoretisch
an Stellen dein Fahrzeug
je nachdem wo,
wenn es eine freie Parkstelle
ist, unbegrenzt lange stehen lassen.
Oder? Wie war das? Muss man
irgendwann umparken?
Ich frage es den Seiten.
Man sieht doch immer mal hier und da so ein Werbehänger
stehen, wo einfach bloß ein Werbeschild drauf ist.
Da könntest du auch sagen, ich stelle jetzt hier mal irgendwo Hänger hin, wo du dein Fahrrad draufstellen kannst oder sowas.
Ja, und dann kommt jemand, nimmt den Hänger weg.
Ja, gut, okay, das ist vielleicht doch eher so eine Art Fliegenfalle.
Na gut, okay, vielleicht auch nicht.
Nee, aber da gibt es sicherlich gute Lösungen für.
Ja, es kommt drauf an, mit wem man darüber redet.
Ich habe mir mehrere, vor der letzten Stadtratswahl habe ich mir so Verkehrsdiskussionen reingezogen.
Da gab es mehrere von.
Und was mir besonders in Erinnerung geblieben ist, ist der Mensch von der FDP, Holger Zastrow,
falls sich jemand den Namen nicht merken möchte, der dann sein Statement eingeleitet hat mit den Worten,
es wird ja seit Jahren in Dresden alles daran gesetzt, immer mehr Parkplätze zu Fahrradbügeln zu machen.
Da gibt es quasi eine Diktatur der Fahrradbügel.
Der ganze Raum entbrannte in so ein schallendes Gelächter
und er hat es nicht eingesehen.
Wir waren auch zusammen bei dieser ADFC-Veranstaltung,
wo die einzige Fahrradfahrerin aus der FDP zu Besuch war
und die gesagt hat, also ich würde das so machen.
Und wie steht Ihre Partei dazu?
Die würden uns das wahrscheinlich nicht so machen,
aber ich werde das so machen.
Gut, okay, dann brauchen wir doch nicht die FDP wählen,
weil sie werden sich wahrscheinlich nicht durchsetzen können.
Mit dem Slogan ihr Auto würde die FDP wählen.
Hat sie oft auch.
Traurig.
So.
Aber du hast jetzt quasi,
wenn du in Dresden bleibst, hast du einen Job,
wo du mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit fahren kannst?
Ja.
Und in Maimö fährst du dann mit dem Roller.
Aber ich fährste auch mit dem Roller, oder?
Manchmal, ja.
Nicht jeden Tag, aber...
Ach stimmt, du bist ja persönlicher Rollerbesitzer.
Ich bin sogar mit Roller hier.
Wahnsinn, der erste rollerunterstützte Podcast.
Das glaube ich ja wohl auch.
Das ist die erste Akronym-Misierber-Folge, wo ein Gast mit Roller ankommt.
Soweit wir wissen.
Aber ja.
Krass. Kann man hier in der Gegend gut fahren?
Das geht, ne?
Das geht schon.
Du musst da ein bisschen aufpassen, dass jetzt nicht jemand eine Tür aufreißt.
Ein Kollege von mir kommt mit einem motorisierten Skateboard auf Arbeit.
Da denke ich mir auch manchmal, die Straßen geben das doch gar nicht her bei den kleinen Kleinen.
Da muss doch nur irgendwas kommen und du fliegst wirklich.
In der Bay Area haben das super viele Leute benutzt.
Sieht auch echt spaßig aus, muss ich sagen.
Da sind die Straßen breit genug.
Das ist halt nicht mein Ding.
Auf der Straße fährst du eh nicht.
Also da fährst du auf privaten Wegen hauptsächlich, sowas bleiben.
Das Problem ist, je kleiner die Räder oder Rollen, desto empfindlicher sind die halt für irgendwelche Unebenheiten.
Es gibt ja noch dieses Onewheel, das ist so ein Brett mit einem fetten Gummirad in der Mitte.
Das sieht auch super spaßig aus.
Davon fahren hier ein paar rum, das habe ich schon gesehen.
Die sind tatsächlich eindrucksvoll.
Der Kollege von mir, der mit dem Skateboard auf Arbeit kommt, der hat die Räder auch so eine Untertellergröße.
Das sind schon so groß wie bei einem Roller, die stehen richtig an der Seite ab.
Das willst du auch haben, wenn du hier über Kopfsteinflascheinflasch hast.
Damit fährt der einen Abgesenkt-Botstein, kann er damit hochfahren.
Oh, krass, okay.
Du hast ja gerade in Dresden jemand, bei meinem Großeltern fährt mir gerade einen,
die wohnen in der äußeren Neustadt hinten.
Die haben, in der Jägerstraße, falls jemand was sagt,
das ist schon immer Kopfsteinpflaster gewesen.
Und vor kurzem haben die halt die halbe Straße aufgerissen
und in der Mitte einen geteerten Streifen gemacht
und an dem Rand die Parkflächen halt Kopfsteinpflaster gelassen.
Sieht echt gut aus.
Und mein Opa ist halt alter Akustiker und der hat es tierisch gefreut,
weil die geteerte Straße viel, viel angenehmer und ruhiger ist,
Als Kopfsteinfasser? Logischerweise.
Auf jeden Fall. Und nach der Hälfte der Straße
ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Stadt
das gar nicht genehmigt hatte und
die Straße unter Denkmalschutz steht und da stand wohl
kurz zur Debatte, das nochmal rückzubauen.
Total bescheuert.
Geht mal gar nicht.
Ich meine, diese schöne
antike Kopfsteinoptik geht dann halt weg.
Scheiß doch auf, das Denkmalschutz
bei einem Kopfsteinfasserstraße ist ja sowas von
altbacken und bekloppt in jeglicher Hinsicht.
Aber das sieht nicht mal schön aus.
Ich überlege gerade mal, ob man
über so eine Kopfsteinpflasterstraße
vielleicht so einen
transparenten Asphalt oben drüber machen könnte,
dass du diese Optik behältst, aber trotzdem
eine ebene Straße. Transparenter Asphalt.
Können wir uns darauf einigen, dass wenn Kopfsteinpflasterstraße,
dann aber auch nur Pferdekutschen drüber?
Wenn wir Mittelalter
haben wollen, dann nicht richtig.
Dann verkleben wir die Kanten mit Pferdekacken
und dann fährt sich das auch wieder glatt drüber.
Ich möchte es doch nicht mehr haben.
Kopfsteinpflasterstraßen,
sowas von unnötig und falsch.
Das hat einfach null Vorteile.
Es sieht nicht schön aus, es ist viel zu laut.
Es ist auf jeden Fall viel zu laut, das stimmt.
Das Einzige, was angenehm ist, ist mit Barfußschulen drüberlaufen.
Ich finde halt so eine Kopfsteinpflaster,
dass sie sieht,
wenn es in Richtung Begeben ist,
sieht es halt hübsch aus.
Ich sag mal, Prag würde anders aussehen,
wenn du über Asphalt einziehen würdest.
Ja, also Asphalt hat halt sowas,
es wirkt halt so.
Du willst sie auch nicht komplett zutären, die ganze Stadt.
Kannst du auch nicht.
Du kannst dich den kompletten Boden
komplett versiegelt.
Kannst du schon.
Wenn du in dem
Waldstück
der Dresdner Heide
die ganzen asphaltierten
Wege rausreißt, dann kannst du hier ein bisschen mehr
asphaltieren.
Ach Gott, die Geschichte.
Dresden war
mehrmals...
Regine hieß die Frau.
Wenn Dresden bei extra 3 für den Unsinn
der Woche mal vorkommt, dann meistens
wegen irgendwelchen Fahrrad- oder Straßengeschichten.
Einmal, dass sie diesen Tunnel wieder zuschütten wollten.
Das war teurer, als den Tunnel restaurieren,
aber sie haben es trotzdem gemacht.
Einmal dafür, dass sie bei der Albertbrücke
diesen historischen Geländer wieder hingemacht haben.
Aber das war nicht hoch genug,
deswegen haben sie dann neben noch ein neues Geländer gemacht,
was jetzt doppelt scheiße aussieht.
Dann Regine Töberich den Elberradweg.
Dafür, dass Regine Töberich den Elberradweg
an ihrem Grundstück
einfach ohne Genehmigung und ohne Absicherung
hat wegbaggern lassen, nur um dann festzustellen,
dass es doch nicht ihr Grundstück war.
Ich meine, ich habe aber tatsächlich
auch diese Sache mit der Dresden...
Und dann halt diese Geschichte, dass in Dresden
die Stadt festgestellt hat, oh, wir haben zu viele
asphaltierte Flächen, wir müssen aus Umweltschutz
oder Wasserversickerungsgründen jetzt wieder
asphaltierte Flächen
wieder auflösen
und haben sich halt dafür entschieden, den Radweg in der Dresdner
Heide wegzubaggern.
Mitten im Wald haben sie dadurch Versickerungsflächen geschaffen.
Im Wald.
Ja, natürlich, im Wald.
Weil im Wald ja nichts versickern.
Im fucking Wald.
Da gibt es so ein paar asphaltierte Wege.
Das ist doch so eine reine Zahlenfrage.
Wir müssen irgendwo wegwerfen.
Das geht hier in der Stadt, das ist ja kacke, da beschweren sich ja Leute.
Nur da, wo muss die Fahrradfahrer lang wollen.
In der Heide.
Idiot.
Ich meine, das wirkt schon ein bisschen komisch,
eine asphaltierte Straße mitten im Wald zu haben.
Das stimmt, aber die war tatsächlich echt gut.
Es ist ein fucking Fahrradweg.
Die war als Fahrradweg gut,
die war als Joggingstrecke.
Was ist mit dem Stück da an der Elbe hinten,
hinter der Saloppe da, wo es da plötzlich hier ist?
Oh ja, da wird es plötzlich wirklich
halbericht. Das ist auch noch richtig kack, Fahrradweg da,
hoch zum Blauen Wunder.
Geht gar nicht da lang.
Das können sie auch mal asphaltieren.
Da gab es doch auch irgendwas, da gab es auch ein Video zu.
Doch, doch, da gab es was.
Der Elbradweg ist generell nochmal eine ganz
andere Geschichte.
Der Krieg, der da ausgetragen wird,
den wollen wir am besten gar nicht erst anfangen
zu dramatisieren. Das ist albern.
Ich war jetzt die letzten Tage
immer mal wieder abends an der Elbe. Es ist ja zur Zeit
Palaisommer. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mal da gewesen seid.
Letztlich, ja.
Dresdner Kulturempfehlung.
Du meinst nicht Kaisermania?
Das war Code dafür.
Ah, verstehe.
Ja, tatsächlich, ich war bei einem Roland-Kaiser-Konzert.
Nee, ich war tatsächlich gestern
und vorgestern jeweils bei einem Konzert.
Und gestern und vorgestern war jeweils auch
Roland Kaiser in Dresden. Ich habe jedes Mal mitbekommen,
oh Gott, hier sind so viele seltsame Menschen
in der Stadt unterwegs, die alle zu diesem Konzert gegangen sind.
Aber nein, ich war nicht bei Roland Kaiser. Ich war beim
Palais Sommer und Palais Sommer ist beim japanischen
Palais quasi
von der Altstadt auf der
Neustädter, äh,
an der Elbe auf der Neustädter Seite ein Stückchen
von der Altstadt weg
Richtung Westen.
Da ist, wie gesagt, diese große Palaiswiese
und da ist...
Wo der Kanäle-Duplik auch ist, oder? Ja, genau, noch ein Stückchen
weiter nach Richtung aus der Stadt raus.
Und da ist Palaisommer.
Und Palaisommer ist
ein Monat lang jeden Abend Kulturprogramm.
Du kannst einfach hingehen mit
einem Klappstuhl oder mit der Picknickdecke
und dich auf die Wiese setzen.
Eintritt ist generell frei.
Dann gibt es da noch so ein paar Stände, wo du Essen und Getränke
kaufen kannst. Sehr cool.
Und da sind,
da kannst du frühs und
so späten Nachmittags zum Yoga gehen.
Da gehen sehr viele
mit ihrer Yoga-Matte hin, auch von meinen
so nach der Arbeit. Und danach
ist dann entweder Konzert oder Lesung
oder Hörspielabend.
Genau, und gestern Abend war ich
bei, da war Singer-Songwriter-Abend,
da haben drei Bands gespielt und danach haben sie noch
einen Film gezeigt.
Warum nicht? Dafür habe ich dann hinterher
freiwillig einen Zehner in irgendeiner Box gedrückt.
Und das hätte ich aber auch nicht machen müssen.
Das ist total schön, das ist in der Stadt.
Na klar, die Kaiserkarten werden teurer geworden.
Ja, die haben dann zwischendurch
überlegt, oh, jetzt wird es ein bisschen frisch, wollen wir jetzt schon
gehen? Aber wenn wir jetzt gehen, dann laufen wir voll
die ganzen Leute, die in dieses Roland-Kaiser-Konzept...
Wir haben von dort nicht locker noch Roland-Kaiser?
Nee, da war es glücklicherweise schon
ein Stückchen weg, weil es auch so um die Elbe drumrum
so ein Schlecker...
Wir haben definitiv die Suchscheinwerfer und das Feuerwerk noch gesehen.
Achso, die...
Ja, genau.
Das ist schon was da denn los.
Aber Palaisoma kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Schließe mich an. Großartig.
Kann man ruhig mal hingehen.
Gibt es auch hin und wieder so eine Aktion, dass man da
malen kann. Stehen sich denn Leute mit
Staffeleien hin und malen Dinge
in einer großen Menge.
Also diesen Massen-Yoga wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
ob ich mich da anschließen würde, weil ich da eigentlich, glaube ich,
einfach nicht der Yoga-Typ bin, aber...
Sieht auf jeden Fall lustig aus, wenn du nicht damit rechnest und einfach
vorbeifährst und auf einmal stehen da halt
500 Leute und machen Yoga.
500 bis 1000 Leute eher.
Genau.
So, das sind so Dresdner Kulturtipps
zurzeit.
Wollen wir in unserem Pad noch ein bisschen weitergucken?
Wir haben überhaupt noch nichts Technisches,
wir haben ganz kurz über...
Ich sehe was zu Actics hier, Volltechnik, ganz kurz.
Was ist denn hier für ein Chips, drum passiert?
Das habe ich bloß so überlegt,
ins Thema aufzunehmen.
Wir können auch noch ein bisschen über Neo4j reden.
Wir haben ja vorhin mittendrin aufgehört.
Was kann man hier jetzt sehen?
Möchten wir da noch ein bisschen ausholen?
Irgendeine Frage hatte ich noch zu Graph-Datenmarken allgemein.
Wenn ich die jetzt noch wüsste,
gut, dass ich es angeschnitten habe.
Ne, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Zum Thema, wie verhalten die sich zu anderen
nicht?
wie heißt das?
In NoSQL-Datenbanken oder macht es Sinn
mit GraphQL irgendwie?
Du hast ja hauptsächlich
an dieser
Neo4j eigenen
Absprachesyntax
gearbeitet. Genau, ich arbeite an der
Anfragesprache Cypher.
Darf ich nur mal anmerken
euer Namenschema?
Das sehr Matrix
inspirierte Namenschema. Das kommt davon,
wenn man einen Chef hat, der so
aus einer Nerd-Ecke kommt.
Welcher Chef in einer IT-Firma kommt nicht aus der Nerd-Ecke?
Naja, es gibt schon auch
IT-Firmen, die quasi von den
Wirtschaftlern gegründet werden und
die sich da nicht rausentwickeln.
Unser Chef hat halt wirklich auch
Code-Zeilen geschrieben und du siehst hin und wieder mal,
wenn du durch die
Files scrollst, dass du hin und wieder mal
die Header der Files, doch nochmal steht
ein E-Mail-Efrem dran.
Das heißt, euer Produkt
heißt Neo, die Sprache heißt
Cypher.
Es gibt noch APOC Procedures.
Awesome Procedures on Cypher, APOC.
Gibt es noch etwas, was Trinity heißt?
Nein, aber wir haben ein Projekt,
das zwischenzeitlich Morphos hieß.
Natürlich.
Naming Things is hard.
Das darfst du immer so ein Konzept haben.
Das sagt er auf einem Podcast, der akronomisierbar heißt.
Die erste Version, die nicht veröffentlichte Version dieses Podcasts,
hieß Naming Things.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich kann euch einen meiner Lieblings-April-1st-Jokes
auf unserem Blog mal kurz näher bringen,
da gab es einen richtig langen Artikel
über, wir nennen uns um.
Wir haben es begriffen, unser Name ist irgendwie
bescheuert. Wer will denn schon Neo4j
heißen? Vor allem, wenn du eine Datenbank hast,
die nicht nur auf Java läuft.
Das ist als Java-Library irgendwann mal gestartet,
aber das sind wir schon lange nicht mehr.
Wir haben es verstanden.
Wir nennen uns um.
Ab jetzt heißen wir Neo5j.
Bitte.
Daher gab es vorher Neo3j
und Neo 2J? Natürlich nicht.
Aber da müsst ihr gleich Neo 5G nehmen,
ist ja viel passender für die Industrie.
Gott.
Naja,
Neo 4.0.
Was lustig ist, weil da arbeiten wir gerade dran.
Also an Neo 4J 4.0
tatsächlich. Das wird das
nächste große Release.
Da dürfte auch, je nachdem
wann dieser Podcast online kommt,
Montag
ein Milestone für erscheinen.
Montag ist morgen.
Ja, Montag ist morgen.
Mal gucken, wann der Podcast kommt.
Deswegen bin ich mir recht sicher, dass ich sagen darf,
dass der A erscheint.
Krass, wir sind heute noch verblieben.
Das hatte ich eigentlich vor.
Richtig, krass.
Ciao mal.
Genau, viele neue tolle Features,
in denen man rumspielen kann.
Neue Features sind immer toll.
Du hast vor allem den Vorteil, dass du an einem Open-Source-Projekt
arbeitest. Ich darf leider nicht wirklich erzählen,
was bei uns intern passiert. Das ist ein bisschen schade.
Ich darf auch nicht alles erzählen.
Also, denke ich.
Bisher habe ich noch nicht gefragt.
Bisher ist noch nicht viel erzählt.
Also ist legitim, über alles zu reden.
Um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen.
Eigene Anfragesprache, Cypher.
Stimmt, da war man.
Genau.
Darum, also in dem Team arbeite ich.
Und wir haben halt angefangen mit dieser eigenen Pattern-Matching-Sprache,
die sich sehr an ASCII-Art erinnert, von der Struktur her.
Und die ist auch einer der Gründe, warum Leute Neo4j auf jeden Fall benutzen oder gerne benutzen.
Wir haben dann irgendwann angefangen, ein eigenes Projekt zu machen, um diese Sprache zu Open-Sourcen.
Heißt Open-Cypher.
Und da haben dann angefangen, viele Leute daran rumzuarbeiten, aus verschiedenen Bereichen.
und nicht nur, im Prinzip haben wir die Sprache mehr oder weniger verschenkt,
damit andere Leute da mit reinkommen können.
Was haben andere da für ein Interesse dran?
Wird das noch von anderen Tools eingesetzt, von anderen Graph-Datenbanken-Tools?
Auch, es gibt Menschen, die da auch Interesse haben, die Sprache auch zu verwenden,
ihre eigenen Extensions mit reinzubringen, ihre eigenen Erweiterungen,
Dinge mit reinzubringen, die halt noch fehlen, darüber zu reden,
wie die sich entwickeln sollen und so weiter.
Und dafür ist dieses OpenCypher-Projekt halt gestartet,
das gerade ein bisschen einen Schritt zurück gemacht hat,
weil wir jetzt eher in die Richtung gehen,
dass wir eine neue Sprache wollen,
die äquivalent zu SQL in relationalen Systemen
der Standard für Graph-Systeme ist.
Und die wird GQL heißen,
die kämpft sich gerade durch diverse Institutionen
damit die genauso standardisiert ist
wie SQL. Aber gutes
Projekt, glaube ich. Ist SQL standardisiert?
Auf jeden Fall.
SQL ist die einzige standardisierte
und Standard mit dem großen S,
nicht ein kleines,
international standardisierte
Datenbank-Abfragesprache, die es überhaupt gibt.
Aber ich dachte, es hat trotzdem
jeder wie MySQL und PostgreSQL
und SQLite, trotzdem ihre
eigenen Dialekte.
Das ist der Witz an dem SQL-Standard,
nachdem ich jetzt ein bisschen weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Der Standard ist ein riesengroßes Dokument.
Und am Anfang stehen alle Sachen drin,
die alle gleichzeitig haben müssen.
Und dann war das Ding, dass...
Und dann ist jeder Dialekt auch noch spezifiziert.
Da hat bestimmt Oracle daherkommt und irgendeinen Scheiß gemacht.
Am Anfang hat er halt...
Jetzt gekauft und zugebracht.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer es war.
Vielleicht war es IBM, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Die hatten auf jeden Fall schon einen Vorsprung,
weil die hatten das alles schon.
Und die anderen hatten dann was anderes
und die wollten halt nichts nachsehen haben.
Also was sie am Ende gemacht haben,
ist im Prinzip diese ganzen
unterschiedlichen Entscheidungen
als Vendor-Extensions quasi auch zu
zertifizieren. Das heißt, du hast
am Anfang einen großen Teil, den alle machen müssen
und dann hast du halt verschiedene Sachen, sowas wie
du kannst jetzt
Date-Types zum Beispiel
so lösen oder so
oder so und das ist auch alles Standard.
Trotzdem standardisiert. Es ist irgendwo
ein Standard.
Das Konzept Standard nicht so ganz verstanden.
Das verwirrt
die Anwender halt total.
das sehe ich total ein, aber das ist halt
standardisiert dadurch.
Das ist doch bescheuert. Im besten Fall enden wir
nicht so in GQL.
Stell dir mal vor, bei
den Browser Wars hätten
sie hinterher auch gesagt, pass auf, was die ganzen einzelnen
Browser-Hersteller in den 90ern sich selber
ausgedacht haben, das wird ja jetzt einfach alles so,
wie es gerade ist, standardisiert und es kann trotzdem jeder
sein eigenes Subset implementieren.
Aber wir schweifen gerade ab.
Wir waren bei GQL,
jetzt frage ich mich als ein bisschen Außenstehender
oder vielleicht auch gerade für die Zuhörer,
wir haben jetzt schon das eine oder andere Mal
über GraphQL geredet oder
das ist auch gerade so in aller Munde, wie verhält sich
das jetzt beides zueinander? Ich meine, GraphQL
schmeißt man jetzt nicht unbedingt auf Graphen-Datenbanken,
aber da ist irgendwie der Name Graph, das Wort
Graph mit dem Namen. Das hat mich auch
am Anfang sehr verwirrt.
GraphQL
unterstützen wir per se
jetzt nicht direkt, aber es gibt
wie es so ziemlich
alles gibt, ein Plugin,
dass du einfach in deine Datenbank reinwerfen kannst
und auf einmal hast du einen GraphQL Endpoint
und kannst alles, was du möchtest, mit GraphQL machen.
Es gibt da ein Projekt, das sich der GrandStack nennt.
Weiß schon gar nicht mehr, worum es da in dem Akronym ging.
Das G steht garantiert auch für Graphen.
Kannst du aber.
Und das N steht für Neo da drin.
Aber auf jeden Fall kannst du innerhalb dieses Stacks
GraphQL auf Neo
auf jeden Fall auch benutzen und
es ist relativ einfach.
Wir haben eine größere
Gruppe an
Developer Relations
Menschen, die tatsächlich
wenn sowas aufkommt, das
direkt umsetzen. Also die sind total
cool. Wenn irgendwas fehlt,
kannst du die Uhr danach stellen, dass das demnächst
als irgendein Plugin oder als Library,
die du dir einfach nur in die Datenbank reinwerfen musst,
einfach verfügbar ist.
Es gibt zum Beispiel eine Menge Dinge, die einfach fehlen in der Anfragesprache,
die wir jetzt auch nicht sofort reinwerfen, weil man halt darüber lange reden muss,
ob das wirklich Sinn macht, ob die Syntax Sinn macht, ob das irgendwie langfristig und so weiter.
Also Spracheentwicklung dauert echt lange und geht durch diese Menge Gremien.
Vor allem, wenn du halt noch so ein Open-Source-Gremium dazwischen geschaltet hast,
wo du nicht nur Firmen intern entscheidest.
Und dann fehlen Dinge einfach in der Sprache.
Dafür haben wir zum Beispiel, um kurz vorzugreifen, diese Awesome Procedures on Cypher,
dieses Repository, im Prinzip eine große Open-Source-Library,
wo du einfach Procedures hast, die zum Beispiel Dinge machen, die du in Cypher noch nicht tun kannst.
Beispielsweise hast du eine Procedure, wo du sagen kannst,
du führst jetzt einen Befehl aus, der zum Beispiel irgendwas schreibt,
und den batchst du. Das heißt,
der macht automatisch eine Transaktion auf,
führt diesen Befehl aus,
sagen wir mal tausend Mal,
und nach tausend Mal macht die Transaktion zu,
committet die und macht sie wieder auf und so weiter und so fort,
so lange, wie du das willst.
Das ist jetzt ein Feature, den du in der Sprache so nicht hast.
Das ist einfach.
Aber mit der Procedure kannst du einfach,
ganz normal,
musst dich um nichts kümmern, ist alles da.
So Developer Relations,
das kann ich mir auch vorstellen,
das ist ein ziemlich geiler Job.
bist viel auf irgendwelchen Konferenzen
und hagst so Kleinigkeiten
wo Leute Bock drauf haben.
Der Relations Team sind generell witzig.
Also wenn man den Kontakt hat als Developer.
Das sind
alles sehr
sehr nette Menschen.
Michael Hunger, mit dem ich
durch den ich in die Nummer und reingekommen bin
im Prinzip macht das jetzt schon ewig
und wenn du den Namen
irgendwo in der Community erwähnst, die wissen alle, wer
Michael Hunger ist.
Das ist auch der Mensch, der dir
morgens um drei irgendwie auch noch auf Stack Overflow
eine Antwort schreibt.
Das ist dann wieder kein so gutes Zeichen.
Kommt drauf an.
Er ist cool. Er ist wirklich cool.
Aber zumindest jetzt, also GraphQL
geht als Plugin quasi
und das ist dann so ein Abstraktionslayer, was das
für dich übersetzt und dann die Anfragen einfach.
Aber ich meine, konzeptionell, wie
verhält sich so ein GraphQL zu einem
kannst du das irgendwie ausdrücken?
Völlig unterschiedliche
Anmodusfragen. Ich meine, bei GraphQL
mache ich ja so eine Art, eigentlich hat
GraphQL selber nicht so viel mit Graphen zu tun, wenn ich es richtig
verstehe, weil du eher so eine Art
ad hoc als Pattern-Matching hinschickst
und dir dann quasi was Ausgefülltes
zurückgeben lässt.
Und bei Graph,
bei Cypher
beschreibe ich so eine Art Untergraph
von meiner Datenstruktur,
wo ich,
obwohl,
ohne wirklich Ahnung zu haben,
soweit ich weiß, GraphQL ist mehr so
was, was du benutzt, um
Daten, die du willst
beschreiben, inklusive deiner
Endpoints, die du hast und
APIs, die du irgendwie damit bündelst.
Und Cypher
ist jetzt wirklich nur dazu
da, um eine Anfrage
auf einem Datengrafen
zu machen,
sei es auf Neo4j, sei es auf irgendeinem
anderen System, gibt ja jetzt
dank OpenCypher diverse andere Sachen,
um da einfach
ein Pattern-Matching zu machen,
um das zu filtern, um irgendwie
Anfragen einfach
inhaltlich auszuführen, weil
GraphQL im Hintergrund, in dem
Plugin nutzt dann halt auch Cypher oder die
APIs, die drunter sind, um dir
diese Antworten zu geben.
Zumindest das Plugin, das ich
gerade denke. Genau, und
Cypher ist halt das
Mittel, das die Datenbank
halt verwendet, um
die Antworten zu geben, die du suchst.
Okay, also
schaut es euch einfach mal an.
Du hattest mal in einem Talk vor einer Weile,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, in welchem Rahmen das war,
über E-Commerce und
Recommendations Engines, glaube ich, gesprochen.
Gibt es generell auch Sachen, die du meint,
deiner Meinung nach, die sich nicht wirklich anbieten,
um in eine Kraft-Taten mal reinzuhauen?
Es ist nicht so,
dass jeder Art
Technologie
so eine eierlegige Wollmichsau
produzieren kann.
Außer du bist SAP,
dann baust du sowas und verkaufst sowas.
bin ich sicher, ob es das trotzdem macht.
Ich würde sagen, es gibt Anwendungsfälle,
wo du halt aus dem Graph nichts ziehst.
Achso, wo ein Graph an sich gar nicht praktisch ist.
Du kannst alles damit tun, klar.
Aber ob du einen Mehrwert rausziehst,
kommt auf deine Daten an.
Sobald deine Daten irgendwie vernetzt sind,
macht es Sinn,
einen Graph draus zu machen.
Also du hast nicht nur soziale Netzwerke
oder Banktransaktionen,
die du als Graph auffassen kannst.
Es gibt vieles.
Es gibt Leute, die Wissensmanagement damit machen.
Sowas wollte ich tatsächlich mal basteln, sowas in der Richtung.
Es gibt Leute, die versuchen Krebs zu heilen mit Patientendaten und mit Treatments,
die du halt miteinander verschachtelst und guckst, wie Leute reagieren auf bestimmte Sachen und so weiter.
Das kannst du halt in einem Graph ablegen und dann versuchst du Muster zu finden
und auch Recommendations zu machen, wie, was, wo besser geholfen hat.
Aber wenn du jetzt, also ich habe es nie ausprobiert,
kann nur aus dem luftleeren Raum sprechen,
aber wenn du jetzt wirklich, sagen wir mal,
du ziehst einfach nur Messwerte von irgendwas,
die einfach nur ein Timestamp und einen Wert haben.
Das ist jetzt, klar kannst du in den Graph werfen,
kannst du Relationships dazwischen setzen,
hast jetzt aber auch nicht den Mehrwert,
als wenn du das in eine Tabelle knallst und halt so auswertest.
Da gibt es Sinn, ja.
Aber die meisten Dinge sind tatsächlich, wenn man genug Daten hat, einfach einen Graph.
Sollte man wirklich mal mit rumspielen, um einfach so ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen,
dass man dafür Mehrwert rausziehen kann, auf jeden Fall.
Kann ich empfehlen. Es macht sehr viel Spaß und du kannst alles mögliche in den Graph kippen
und da du halt kein wirkliches Schema hast, kannst du halt alle Sachen kombinieren
und wilde Anfragen ausführen, die du vorher überhaupt nicht nachgedacht hast.
Das ist mal toll.
Das würde mich allgemein mal interessieren, wenn jetzt der Trend eher dazu geht,
dass der Client sich bei vielen Anwendungen,
die wir jetzt sehen, bei
Gatsby-Anwendungen oder
Web-Anwendungen, wenn es dazu hingeht, dass
du dir auf Client-Seite die Anfragen ja ausdenkst
und nicht so fest daran
gebunden bist, dass du ein bestimmtes Schema
auf Server-Seite hast,
dann nicht vielleicht
längerfristig der Trend eh dahin geht, dass du
dann eine KF-Datenbank einfach dahinter machst und einfach
unstrukturierte Daten reinschmeißt
und dann von Client-Seite viel flexibler auf diese
Sachen zugreifen kannst.
Es kommt einfach von, was du machst, wenn du
selber explorierst, klar, kannst du machen, was du willst.
Wenn du das natürlich irgendwie auswertest,
musst du schon irgendwie
wissen, was du halt abfragst.
Also im besten Fall zumindest.
Du kannst natürlich Grafalchorithmen raufwerfen
und versuchen, irgendeine
Systematik in den Daten zu finden,
ob es irgendwelche Cluster gibt,
ob es da so Haufen gibt,
die keine Verbindung zur Außenwelt haben
und dann guckst du dir die an zum Beispiel.
Gibt es gute Visualisierungstools,
die man direkt draufheffen kann?
Diverse. Wir haben
zwei
eigene im Prinzip.
Wir haben einen Neo4j Browser,
das ist so eine Entwicklungsumgebung,
Konsole,
mit dem man halt ein bisschen
rumexperimentieren kann.
Da kann man Queries reinwerfen
und dann kann man sich das angucken
und dann kann man den Graphen, der da rausfällt,
selber noch ein bisschen explorieren, der ist ein bisschen limitiert.
Das heißt, irgendwann sagt er dir,
ja, mehr möchte ich
hier nicht anzeigen, sonst schirbt dein Browser dir weg.
Und dann haben wir ein
neues Tool, das sich Bloom nennt.
Mit dem kannst du wirklich
Grafexplorationen machen,
mehr oder weniger
unbegrenzt.
Und
das nutze ich zum Beispiel,
wenn ich ein bisschen Spaß haben will, mit
meinem
Site-Project, was so ein bisschen Open Data
in Neo reinwerfen und dann selber mal gucken,
wo ich lande.
Darüber habe ich
auch schon mal einen Meetup-Vortrag gehalten.
tatsächlich rede ich darüber in
meinem Conference Talk
bei New York Sachsen Day dieses Jahr.
Ah, sehr gut, dass du es
ansprichst. Ich habe gerade gesucht, ob ich von
Logbuch-Netzpolitik diese Termin-
Vorschlags-Melodie irgendwie
bei uns abspielen könnte.
Aber ich sehe, du hast tatsächlich
sogar in unserer Pad in der Vorbereitung
ein paar Termine
für die, die in nächster Zeit
in der Umgebung anstehen,
reingeschrieben. Das finde ich total geil.
Sollten wir öfter machen.
Sollten wir allgemein öfter machen.
Das war genau mein Gedanke, dass ihr das öfter machen solltet.
Das kommt ja sogar mit Verbesserungsvorstellungen.
Also an dieser Stelle, da wir
häufig von diesem Termin auch nicht unbedingt wissen
oder manchmal den Podcast
nicht kurzzeitig
genug vorbereiten,
sondern dass er bei uns noch zwei Wochen rumliegt,
bevor wir dann wirklich, also wir sind einfach nicht
zeitsouverän genug
oder kurzfristig genug.
Klappt das häufig nicht, aber hier bei diesem Termin
könnte es tatsächlich sogar klappen.
Und zwar
in the Day, ist der hier mit drin?
Nee, den hast du gerade nicht aufgezählt. Den habe ich nicht mit aufgezählt.
Das liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass der schon ausverkauft
ist. Achso.
Also, wer da ist... Also, wenn ihr zufällig
schon eine Karte für Jux 6 in the Day
2019 habt, dann werdet ihr
dort auf Sasche treffen.
Könnt ihr ihm ja einen Kaffee ausgeben?
Vor Ort macht das keinen Sinn, weil es alles drin ist.
Kann ich eine lustige
Anekdote dazu erzählen?
Ein uns allen bekannter Mensch,
dessen Name jetzt mal nicht genannt wird,
hat mir neulich offenbart, dass seine Firma
Premium-Sponsor des Jogs Xenny Days
ist, aber leider haben sie verkackt,
für die Entwickler Tickets
zu kaufen.
Das heißt, da wären vor Ort nur die beiden Hanseln
am Stand, die da Entwickler
versuchen anzuwerben sein, aber nicht die ganzen
Entwickler. Das ist sehr schade.
Die beiden Hanseln am Stand sind keine Entwickler?
Soweit ich weiß, das ist eine andere Abteilung,
aber
wie das halt so ist. Das fand ich allgemein
immer komisch. Also ich bin,
ich war jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal
für meine Firma repräsentativ bei der Output
und habe mit Studenten
und potenziellen Bewerbern geredet
und ein bisschen erzählt, was wir so den ganzen Tag dort machen.
Und das halt aus der Perspektive eines Entwicklers,
weil wir Entwickler suchen und keine
Personalabteilungsmitarbeiter.
Aber es gibt halt wirklich auch Firmen,
die dann ihre Personaler
zu solchen Jobmessen oder solchen
allgemeinen Veranstaltungen schicken und die dann da
irgendwie die Firma repräsentieren, wo ich mir dann immer denke,
was soll das, wenn ich da als...
Die Bondage-Messe oder was?
Ja, zum Beispiel die Bonding.
Weile ich doch.
Ganz nah dran.
Da schicken wir zum Beispiel auch, wenn das in Dresden ist, Entwickler hin,
aber es liegt bei uns daran, dass wir in Dresden wirklich ausschließlich Entwickler sind.
Es gibt von unserer Personalabteilung oder Sales, die sitzen alle nicht in Dresden.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel von anderen Firmen mit Leuten geredet und gefragt,
ja, wenn ich dann wirklich, als ich noch Interesse hatte an anderen Firmen, mich zu bewerben,
als ich dann wirklich angefragt habe,
so konkrete technische Fragen zu stellen,
was benutzt ihr jetzt da für eine Programmiersprache
oder was nehmt ihr ein Backend für eine Datenbank
oder sowas, dann hieß es dann immer, ja,
das kann ich dir gar nicht so genau sagen, ich bin eigentlich so
von der Personalabteilung und dann war ich immer kurz
davor zu fragen, was machst du dann hier?
Ja klar,
es ist irgendwie auch der Job von einem Personaler,
dann
sich mit den neuen Leuten auseinanderzusetzen,
aber doch nicht, wenn du
die Firma irgendwie auf einer technischen
Messe vertrittst. Das ist irgendwie schwierig, das sehe ich.
Du kannst natürlich sagen, es gibt Leute, die du halt auch nicht dahin stellen wollen würdest, also die Entwickler sind, weil die einfach fremde Leute eher verschrecken würden, weil die einfach nicht so gut mit neuen Menschen auskommen.
Du kannst nicht jeden schicken, du musst schon irgendwie so jemanden haben, der so ein bisschen extrovertiert ist, aber es sollte halt auch jemand sein, der sich mit der tatsächlichen Arbeit, die die Firma leistet, beschäftigt, weil jemand von der Personalabteilung, ohne jetzt böse über Lerte von Personalabteilung reden zu wollen, aber das könnte ja auch von der Personalabteilung von einer anderen Firma sein, die könnten sich dann untereinander wahrscheinlich über die gleichen Sachen unterhalten, wie sie irgendwie ihre Gehaltsauszahlungsverwaltung machen oder sowas, aber nicht, was die Firma wirklich erstellt.
Anyway, wir wollten über Termine reden.
Und zwar, JuckSexunyDay ist,
hast du das jetzt mal nachgeguckt?
Im September,
irgendwann Mitte.
Genau, ist erst im September.
Wenn ihr jetzt noch keine Karten habt, ja dann
tough luck, wir schreiben es in die Shownotes,
wann es genau ist. Ansonsten, wir haben
über Verkehrssachen in Dresden
und Malmöhl geredet und es ist am
18.8. die
Verkehrswende Dresden-Demo.
Das ist eine Demo
und was genau passiert da?
Eine sehr gute Frage. Im Prinzip ist das eine Demo, die für die anstehenden Landtagswahlen zum 1. September ein bisschen mehr über das Thema private PKWs im städtischen Raum reden möchte, kostenlosen oder besser ausgebauten ÖPNV, sicheres flächendeckendes Radwegenetz.
Hier steht Verkehrswende
die zweite, das erste Mal, weil so eine
große Fahrradtour, die da gemacht wird.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das die gleiche Sache ist.
Wenn es die ist, wunderbar,
weil das war richtig toll.
Das war ja so eine Art große,
organisierte Critical Mass, bloß mit
Polizeibetreuung diesmal.
Also 18.8.
Die URL mit den Details ist
in den Shownotes. Am 24.8.
ist unteilbar.
Was ist unteilbar?
Lustigerweise ist es nicht am 18.8.
sondern am 13. Nacht nicht.
Also,
zack, ändert sich so ein Pad.
Sehr gut.
Unteilbar war, glaube ich,
letztes Jahr in Chemnitz, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
War das die Sache mit den Konzerten? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Nee, das ist, wir sind mehr.
Ach, verdammt. Aber im Prinzip geht es um das Gleiche.
Es geht darum,
zu zeigen, dass
die Zivilgesellschaft mehr ist
als der kleine rechte Rand, der hier immer wieder
leider in den Nachrichten ist
und entsprechend
zu zeigen, dass wir uns nicht spalten lassen
von irgendwelchen rechten
Pegida-Hetzern oder AfD-Menschen,
in Ermangelung eines anderen Wortes,
und einfach ein Zeichen zu setzen
vor der Landtagswahl,
dass wir mehr sind,
dass wir uns nicht teilen lassen
von rassistischer Hetze.
Und entsprechend kann ich nur jedem empfehlen,
da auf jeden Fall dabei zu sein.
Finde ich gut.
danach ist am 1.
September ist Landtagswahl
in Sachsen. Bitte keine Nazis
wählen steht hier. Also einfach der
Aufruf von, das hast alles du
hier reingeschrieben.
Das ist richtig.
Wenn in Sachsen wohnt, geht wählen.
Genau. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch
den Podcast von André Herrmann
und Julius Fischer hört.
Teamtotale Zerredung.
Die enden immer mit den Worten
Bitte wählt
Nazi-Sympathisanten. Finde ich gut.
Und ich finde, das kann man überall mal ruhig erwähnen.
Team
Totale Zerredung. Genau.
Kommt in den Notizen, habe ich glaube ich noch nicht gehört.
Okay, also wo wir jetzt gerade
E-Sachen empfehlen. Jetzt ist noch der letzte
Punkt. Am 20. September ist dann
Alle fürs Klima. Es ist
Friday for Future Dresden.
Weltweit tatsächlich. Oder nee, das stimmt ja.
Es steht nicht Dresden. Fridayforfuture.de
slash Alle fürs Klima ist auch eine Demo.
Genau, es ist eine Demo, die weltweit
stattfindet. Die haben schon mal einen internationalen
Streik gemacht und das wird
jetzt nochmal größer.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich ein Streik?
Ich gehe da einen Arbeitsschwänzen an dem Tag?
Wenn du kannst, mach. Ich habe mir
Urlaub genommen tatsächlich.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen Urlaub
dieses Jahr, deswegen dachte ich, komm, dafür
kannst du ruhig frei machen. Außerdem ist es
ein Freitag, da kannst du eh... Stimmt.
Also wer Urlaub hat,
nehme sich den Urlaub,
mach damit.
Es ist notwendig.
Ist da in Dresden was geplant oder organisiert?
Dresden passiert auch irgendwas.
Ich habe noch keine Details, aber
da wird auf jeden Fall was stattfinden.
Also wir werden uns da wahrscheinlich auf der Straße treffen.
Ja, bitte.
Das waren die Termine.
Ich spiele vielleicht in der Nachbararbeitung noch ein bisschen Musik.
Ja, bevor wir uns jetzt
völlig
in der Destruktur verlieren.
Wir haben ja noch so ein paar Themen im Pad, aber die müssen wir nicht unbedingt nehmen.
Sonst reißen wir die ja nächstes Mal mit an.
Genau.
Ich hätte jetzt noch am Rande erwähnt,
dass es sehr Meetups in Dresden gibt.
Ich habe jetzt vor zwei Wochen
zum vierten Mal
insgesamt meinen WebAssembly-Vortrag
in Dresden gehalten. Das war diesmal bei diesem
Web-Montag und der Web-Montag ist in diesem
Impact Hub.
Da habe ich
einen Tag vorher die letzte Folge
noch endlich zu Ende bearbeitet und kurz überlegt,
Soll ich jetzt einfach Werbung dafür mal mit reinschneiden,
bevor ich es irgendwie hochlade?
Aber nee.
Und ich kann einfach nur empfehlen, schaut euch
dieses Meetup mal an. Das ist eine hübsche, diverse
Gruppe von Leuten, die nicht alle bloß
JavaScript machen, sondern
es ist gut gemixt. Auch mal TypeScript
dazwischen. Und PHP. Sehr, sehr divers.
PHP hat er
glaube ich. Naja, gut.
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich gar nicht.
So divers dann auch nicht.
So.
Haben wir noch andere Themen oder wollen wir direkt zu
GitHub-Stores übergehen.
Können wir auch machen. Haben wir noch ein paar Sachen hier
aufgelistet. Cool.
Kieran, fängt an. Ich habe
ein Chrome-Browser-Extension
auf die Liste gesetzt, obwohl ich es selber nicht nutzen kann,
weil ich Safari-Nuser bin.
Die Browser-Extension heißt Pannengerät-Krank-Knarrenbauer.
Bitte was?
Das ist eine Browser-Extension, die
replaced einen gewissen Namen, nämlich
den Namen Amenschreck-Krebs-Kratzenjammer
mit diversen anderen Random-Namen.
Das wird dann besonders witzig, wenn die Frau erstmal Kanzlerin ist.
Abhörgerät kommt Kampfschubschrauber.
Ist auch schön,
in diese Constant-GS
reinzuschauen. Angriffskrieg,
Krebs, Katzenmiauer.
Wird das immer
auf Hauer oder R auf?
Die Nachnamen Schnackenfauna,
Schinkenklauber, Pfarrenhauer, Neumalschlauer,
Nasenklauer,
Kroatenlauer, Krimakalauer,
Grillverdauer. Also Kroatenlauer ist, glaube ich,
ein bisschen bedenklich, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das okay ist.
Aber auf jeden Fall eine witzige Extension.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an...
Das ist ein Fork von der alten Extension,
die heißt Bumbercar Candy Snatch,
die den Namen Benedict Cumberbatch replaced
mit Sachen wie Wimbledon Tennis Match,
Carlton Thunder Crunch,
Timothy Cawth,
Bandipool Cabbage Patch.
Cabbage Patch.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese Extension,
die...
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese
Extension von der Partei,
die AfD-Themen
aus irgendwelchen Newsseiten rausfiltert.
So für die eigene persönliche Filterblase.
Ob genug erwähnt reicht langsam.
Genau.
Nee, fand ich sehr witzig.
Pannengerät krank Knarrenbauer.
Jetzt wird es ja liebevoll generell AKK 47 genannt.
Ist die zufällig auch Baujahr 47?
Das wäre ein bisschen hart.
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sie heißt.
Annegret Krampf...
Krampf...
Krampf Knarrenbauer, 62 geboren.
Okay.
Sascha?
Ja, ich habe da
unerrateterweise
unsere
APOC-Library, Awesome
Procedures on Cypher,
aus zweierlei Gründen, A, bei Werbung
und B, tatsächlich,
wenn ihr Bock habt,
irgendwas zu kontributen in irgendeiner
Richtung Dinge, coole Dinge, die ihr
meint, dass die Sprache das noch braucht
oder andere Menschen das cool finden würden
und ihr seid zum Beispiel gerade
mitten im
Hacktober zum Beispiel.
Ihr braucht noch ein paar Pull Requests.
Ist tatsächlich
an dem Ding mitzuarbeiten
eine wunderbare Sache, um in die ganze
Graff-Welt reinzukommen, ein bisschen
die APIs, die Neo4j
bietet, sich mal anzugucken.
Ich habe zum Beispiel für
einen Hacktober, habe ich mal
Procedure geschrieben, die die ganze Datenbank
diesen Warm-up
macht, die die ganzen
Daten einmal kurz
sich in den Arbeitsspeicher zieht, damit
die Anfragen, die du danach
machst, einfach schon schneller beantwortet
werden können, weil du halt nicht extra
Sachen von der Platte ziehen musst. Einfach alles
kurz mal schon mal kurz anfassen und umdrehen,
bevor man es dann lebt. Aber das eigentlich in den
Cache-Laden macht Neo4j selber.
Du kannst halt deine Terabytes nicht in
Cache laden, aber du kannst
zumindest, wenn du genug RAM hast,
die ganzen
Grafen erstmal in den RAM laden
und das macht schon mal Dinge besser.
da kann man
mitarbeiten, da werden
Post requests angenommen, da kann man Issues schreiben.
Das ist gut.
Wir sollten von den Leuten,
wir sollten langsam überlegen, ob wir uns nicht von den Firmen
einfach sponsern lassen wollen, wenn wir ihre Mitarbeiter
hier eine Plattform bieten.
Das ist schön, dass ich nichts dafür kriege.
Cool, ja, ich habe
auch was Technisches und zwar ist mir jetzt
kurzem auf Twitter was
begegnet und zwar hat jemand sich gedacht,
Node.js
ist cool, Leute möchten irgendwie immer noch
Webserver in JavaScript schreiben, bloß
dass Node.js irgendwie quasi genauso
viel kann wie jede andere Scriptsprache auf
deinem System auch, nämlich noch
Dateisystem und so anderes Zeugs machen und
Prozess-Environment-Variablen
abfragen ist halt doof. Wir möchten
einen Service bauen, mit dem man wirklich nur
HTTP-Services in JavaScript schreiben kann und
das ist noch nicht 100 pro
ausgebacken, aber es gibt
Das ist Osgood.
Oder, ja, O-S-G-O-O-D.
Ich wusste jetzt nicht, wie man den Namen wirklich ausspricht.
Aber das ist quasi ein System, was auf,
und da gibt es hier einen schönen,
natürlich, Dev.to-Blogpost drüber,
den schmeiße ich mir auch noch mit rein.
Es gibt eine Bank, die so heißt.
Die Osgood, ja, ich weiß nicht, was die Etymologie von dem Namen ist.
Osgood Schlatter Disease.
Es geht aus einem Dr. Who-Charakter, der so heißt.
Und das ist quasi einfach bloß eine Verheiratung von diesem Tokyo Rust-Framework,
mit dem man halt super performante Netzwerkdienste bauen kann und der V8-JavaScript-Rundtripe.
Und dann haben sie dem noch ein bisschen eine javascriptige API gegeben.
Und jetzt kannst du halt so eine Art Express oder andere Arten von Web-Servern damit bauen.
Und es läuft halt nicht mit LibUV, sondern mit Tokio und kann aber sonst wirklich nur Netzwerk.
Aha.
Das finde ich so als Konzept mal ganz nett.
Klingt ja nicht verkehrt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es sich durchsetzen wird,
aber ich finde es schön, dass Leute
in diese Richtung ein bisschen arbeiten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist mal eine coole Verheiratung von zwei Technologien.
Genau.
Kean, hast du noch was?
Ich würde normal noch Swift Format
mit auf die Liste setzen, was jetzt endlich mal
es geschafft hat, Licht das Licht der Welt zu erblicken.
Nach vielen, vielen
Monaten Diskussionen im Swift-Year-Forum
mit ganz, ganz
viel Bike-Shedding, unnötig im Voraus
schon über Diskussionen, was
dann später genaue Regeln angeht und
ganz viel emotional geladene
Debatten, ob ein Formatter
doch gut oder böse ist und was er sich denn erlauben
dürfte, meinen wunderschönen
Code anzufassen und warum der den Code
von anderen Leuten komplett zurechtformatten sollte,
weil mein Stil der einzig wahre ist und so weiter.
Ist jetzt endlich mal das
Repo rausgekommen und es
entwickelt sich langsam ein Tool und ich will gar nicht so viel
oder zu verlieren, außer dass ich toll finde, dass
sowas existiert. Du bist also auch auf der
Seite von I4One
Welcome Our Robot Formatting Overlords.
Ich bin großer Fan von Robot Formatern,
vor allem, weil sie oftmals
dem Stil sprechen, den ich gern nutze.
Ja, also wenn du eh...
Wenn du zufällig schon den Code
so formatieren, wie du es eh gemacht hattest, ist das in Ordnung.
Ansonsten gewöhne ich mich dran. Also ganz ehrlich,
das Ding von Go finde ich klasse.
Go Format ist so eine tolle Idee, von wegen es gibt den
einen Stilpunkt.
Finde ich persönlich super toll. Es gibt
die widersprechen dem sehr gerne, sehr emotional.
Kann ich irgendwo auch nachvollziehen, aber
ich finde es einfach toll.
Ich würde da nicht unbedingt den Begriff emotional
ranhängen, aber... Das ist sowas von emotional
für manche Leute.
Also wenn der Format was richtig hässliches
als Standardeinstellung machen würde, dann wäre es auch für mich ein sehr emotionales
Thema, aber das machen die meistens ja nicht.
Meistens.
Es gibt ja diese komischen Sprachen
wie Haskell, wo es ja typischerweise auch
so eine Formattersache ist, dass man
in der Liste Kommas an den Anfang,
oder Kommata an den Zeilen Anfang packt,
damit die letzte Zeile halt kein Trailing-Komma braucht,
finde ich ganz schrecklich.
Richtig, richtig hässlich.
Ja, und dann wirst du plötzlich emotional.
Ja, eben.
Aber das passiert nicht in den Sprachen, die ich schreibe.
Also was kratzt mich?
Was ficht es mich an?
Also ich finde es dann auch schlimm,
wenn einer sagt, du musst jetzt nicht so emotional reagieren.
Ich reagiere nicht emotional drauf.
Schrei doch nicht so.
Ich schreie nicht.
Ich will nicht, dass der Code so formatiert wird.
Aber nee,
das Einzige, was mir,
Ich habe mich auch mittlerweile an Trailing Commas gewöhnt,
auch wenn ich es komisch finde, weil es ja
doch irgendwie so ein, oder
Leading Pipes bei
Union Types, was ich sinnvoll
finde, sinnlos finde.
Ja, es gibt ja so Union Typen, die du
mit einem Pipe trennst, so dieser Typ ist entweder
dieser oder dieser Zustand und bei
TypeScript und bei
Oh, wir reden ja nicht über Programmiersprache. Bei TypeScript
und bei Haskell
kannst du es so hinschreiben, und bei
Rust mittlerweile auch, dass du
die einzelnen
Zustände von deinem Union alle untereinander
an einzelnen Zeilen schreibst und dann würde ja
normalerweise das erste dann
das Pipe erst nach dem ersten
kommen, weil es ja mehrere Zustände separiert.
Deswegen kannst du das Pipe auch vor
dem ersten schon schreiben. Das heißt, du hast
noch einen Zustand, der
nichts enthält, den gibt es auch gar nicht,
aber du hast da einen Pipe und es lässt sich
einheitlicher hinschreiben. Ich finde es
persönlich ein bisschen sinnlos, genauso wie
ein Trailing-Komma, weil halt nach dem
Komma nichts mehr kommt. Aber Trailing-Kommas sind
toll. Anyway,
Ich mache manchmal gerne
so einen Kommentar, wo ich den
Codeformatter für einen Blog
ausmache, weil er an manchen
Stellen einfach Code erzeugt, der schlechter
lesbar ist, als
er sein könnte. Und mir persönlich,
wie gesagt, das ist mein persönliches Ding,
geht Lesbarkeit vor Einheitlichkeit
vor. Von mir aus könnten die Leute...
Das ist immer irgendwo eine gewisse Abwägung. Genau.
Von mir aus können die Leute gerne mal
und mal 4 Einrückungszeichen nehmen
und mal Trailing-Command und mal nicht. Hauptsache
der Code liest sich besser und ich habe den Eindruck,
wenn ich zum Beispiel Clang-Format,
wenn das Jupp jetzt hört, dann wird er mich bestimmt nachher
anschreiben,
was Clang-Format so aus C++ macht,
ist nicht besser lesbar als wenn es...
Ja, aber C++ ist ja generell nicht lesbar,
also es ist ja so ein Apple-Battle,
die du nicht gefunden hast.
Wollen wir über Scala reden?
Was macht der Scala-Formatierer?
Ach Gott,
ja, zumindest,
Wenn du es von IntelliJ aus benutzt,
dann hast du eine große Auswahl an Dingen,
die er aus Java-Code machen könnte.
Macht er aus Java-Code von alleine Skala-Code?
Nein, nein, nein.
Der formatiert dir deinen Java-Code genauso wie du möchtest.
Aber die Skala-Regeln sind nicht so ausgeprägt.
Und vor allem,
klar kannst du Skala formatieren wie du möchtest,
aber das Problem ist doch,
wenn du irgendwelche partiellen Funktionen
in irgendwelche anderen 100 Dinge
einschachtelst, dann ist egal, wie du es formatierst.
Du kannst es erst
in einer halben Stunde überhaupt lesen.
Aber dafür gibt es dann
nun wieder Linter, wo bei uns
auch
also bei uns ist das ziemlich krass.
Da wirst du als Entwickler ziemlich dolle
eingeschränkt.
Du wirst ständig irgendwie gesagt, das kannst du so nicht machen,
das kannst du so nicht machen.
Das geht mir dann auf den Keks, weil du irgendwelche
Linter hast, bloß weil irgendwann mal irgendwer gesagt hat,
nee, das ist besser als das.
Und dann musst du dich plötzlich an solche Regeln halten,
die, weil du denkst,
ich will doch bloß meinen Code schreiben. Und gerade bei
Go, ich meine, ich schreibe nicht ständig Go und
vielleicht ist es ja in Ordnung, aber
du musst halt deine IDE oder deinen Editor
so einrichten, dass es automatisch formatiert wird.
Aber das musst du halt machen.
Du kannst nicht mal eben was hinhacken
und bloß so zum Rumspielen. Du bist die ganze Zeit am formatieren.
Der nervig wird es halt, wenn der anfängt, der
Formatler halt Dinge rauszulöschen.
Wenn ich TypeScript schreibe,
Dinge, die noch nicht fertig sind, dann
gekickt werden. Genau, das zum Beispiel. Wenn ich TypeScript
schreibe, habe ich ständig während
des Schreibens irgendwelche
Unterkringelungen vom Linter drin.
Manchmal füge ich einen Import hinzu
und dann speichere ich und dann wird mir das Import wieder
gelöscht, weil ich es noch nicht benutze.
Und ich bin die ganze Zeit dabei, irgendwie
in VS Code
dieses Kommando
Autofix auszuführen,
weil ich es nicht von alleine machen lassen will.
Ich möchte schon wissen, wann mein Code verändert
wird unter meinen Fingern. Und das ist einfach
so ein, das ist mittlerweile ehrlich gesagt mehr
Overhead, als es mir erspart.
Und das Fieseste ist, wenn du dann solche Checks,
das ist das, was es bei mir
zu so
Abwehrreaktionen geführt hat,
bei gewissen Repos bei uns läuft es
in der CI, aber erst sehr spät.
Und dann hast du irgendwie schon
anderthalb Stunden auf irgendeinen
Merch-Bot gewartet, dass du
dein PR endlich durchkriegst und dann
hat irgendwo eine Formatierung gefehlt.
Und da kannst du ja nicht mal
sagen, so ein Scheiß
weil dir dann irgendjemand anders sagt,
warum formatierst du das nicht von vornherein?
Ich halte die ganze Zeit
eh schon am formatieren.
Ich habe keinen Bock, mich damit auseinandersetzen.
Du musst dich damit auseinandersetzen.
Du brauchst einfach,
bevor du committest,
so einen Schritt, der sich reinengt
und guckt, ob es passt.
Wir machen hier keine Pre-Commit-Hooks.
Wir hatten das vorher bei dem Repo.
Bevor du was gepusht konntest,
lief irgendwie so ein 20-Sekunden-Skript
und dann hat es...
20 Sekunden?
Ja, also lief nicht 20 Sekunden, aber so ein...
Das ist ja auch affig.
Dann, wenn du
was pushen willst, was
du nicht sofort merchen willst,
dann hast du es
mit NoVerify gepusht.
So kannst du es dann auch nicht merchen. Wenn du es dann irgendwann merchen willst,
dann pusht es dann nochmal so, dass die CIs
dann auch frisst. Aber vorher wird es dann eh rot.
Dann hast du es zumindest...
Ah ja, egal. Das ist ja anstrengend.
Anyway, ich mag es auch nicht, wenn die
Ich finde es sinnlos,
wenn die Einrückungen, die Leerzeichen
quasi zur Syntax deklariert werden,
weil sie quasi Fehler hervorrufen können,
weil sie nicht richtig an richtigen Stellen sind.
Ja, aber du hast vorhin von
ungleichmäßiger Innentation gesprochen.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja ganz schlimm.
Bei Silicon Valley, wo er sich
von seiner Freundin getrennt hat, weil sie
Spaces genutzt.
aber das Dumme an der Folge war, dass sich Spaces halt mit der Leertaste getippt hat.
Das macht doch keine Sau.
Nope.
Vor allem, weil es sinnlos ist, dass er eigentlich der komische Typ war,
weil er Tabs benutzt hat.
Ja, aber er hat ja Tabs benutzt.
Also die Rechtfertigung fand ich cool,
weil das ja weniger Zeichen tatsächlich sind, die dann encoded werden.
Deswegen gibt es die Datei kleiner.
Also das stimmt schon.
Ist halt marginal im Sinne des Rundungsfehler,
aber es stimmt schon.
Und ich fand es cool, dass er halt deswegen auf der Tab-Seite ist,
weil er halt bei einem Dings, bei einem...
Kompressions...
Genau, machen halt einen Compression-Gig da.
Also ich fand die Rechtfertigung cool, aber die Tatsache,
ich meine, das kannst du natürlich nicht den dummen Zuschauer schauen lassen,
dass die halt genauso Spacer einfach nutzt,
aber trotzdem nicht die Leertaste benutzt.
Aber das fand ich ein bisschen affig.
Aber ansonsten, ja, witzige Folge.
Wenn wir jetzt die ganze Thematik Tabs und Spaces mal kurz aufmachen wollen,
da gab es natürlich einen...
Ich weiß genau, was du jetzt referenzierst.
Ein Tweet, der sehr, sehr
schön zusammengefasst hat, dass man ja nur
Tabs benutzen soll, einfach nur, damit man die
seh-eingeschränkten Menschen
nicht benachteiligt.
Weil die
sehen halt Spaces oder
die kriegen halt mit, dass Sachen Spaces sind und können
die nicht so gut unterscheiden zu
ist das jetzt eine Syntax-Eindrückung oder nicht.
Wenn es Tabs sind, wissen die das halt.
Da gab es ein bisschen was mit nicht Syntax-Eindrückung.
Es war ein echt gutes Argument. Ich habe es auch nicht mehr ganz
im Kopf, aber das hatte irgendwie mit Screenreadern
zu tun, dass es halt wirklich eine ziemliche Barriere
ist mit Bases, weil er den Code nicht wirklich...
Weil der Screenreader keine Syntax-Analyse macht, quasi.
Genau, die wissen ja nicht, dass das Code ist.
Ja, das war irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das war aber echt ein gutes Argument.
Schreiben wir jetzt unseren Code anders, weil es irgendwann mal ein Blinder lesen könnte?
Oder arbeiten wir nicht lieber
daran, dass die Screenreader schlauer werden?
Nee, das war nicht ganz so trivial,
dass es damit zu erschlagen war.
Das war schon ein gutes Argument.
Aber trotzdem bleibt es jetzt endlich so,
man sollte nicht eine globale Regel dafür finden,
weil für nichts gibt es die globale gute Regel.
außer keine Nazis wählen.
Aber es ist immer irgendwo eine Gradwarnung.
Wenn dein Team einen Standard hat
und dein Team so gut arbeiten kann
und jeder in dem Team damit zurechtkommt, dann nutzt
diesen Standard und sei nicht der eine, der sich dagegen wendet,
weil du aus persönlichen Gründen, aus religiösen
Gründen da widersprichst.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also allgemein, macht euch untereinander aus,
wie ihr miteinander arbeitet. Hauptsache, ihr könnt
gut miteinander arbeiten. Wenn ihr euch irgendwie
so einem linter und formatierenden Regime unterwerfen
wollt, dann macht das ruhig
oder lasst es sein. Ich habe auch schon
einen sehr wunderschön, liebevoll handformatierten Code
bei uns in der Firma gesehen.
Dann hat es mir immer das Herz gebrochen, wenn er dann autoformatiert wurde.
Also gerade so, wenn so Parameter über mehrere
Zeichen weggeleint sind, das ist schon echt schick.
Gerade so bei Xcode macht das ja automatisch,
weil es halt bei Objective-C Methoden nahm,
die halt so, ich halte meine Arme so ganz weit wie möglich
auseinander, so lang sind.
Das ist halt, da brauchst du sowas, weil sonst ist die Zeile
halt 500 Zeichen lang. Das stimmt, also ich hab
wir können ja mal
Formatierungs-Horror-Stories teilen.
Ich hab dem einen
Projekt, mit dem ich meine Diplomarbeit
geschrieben habe, der hatte der Entwickler, der das
gemacht hat, der hat halt
die ganzen Parameter von Python-Funktionen
und die Python-Funktionen werden ja lang, weil du benahmte
Parameter hast, das heißt, du kannst die Namen
du schreibst die Namen mit rein
ich weiß nicht, kannst du
nicht mehr genau beschreiben, aber die
Funktionssignaturen wurden sehr lang
und der hat
quasi die Parameter
bis zum Zeichenlimit hinten
in eine Zeile geschrieben und dann
nur wenn es absolut nötig war, das letzte umgebrochen
Ikit. Wow.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
muss ich das lesen können?
Und ich bin dann lange Zeit Fan gewesen von
ich breche, was weiß ich, bei dem Charakter,
bei dem Zeichen, wo
die Klammer losgeht, um und
alleine alles darunter.
Der erste Parameter kann ja stehen bleiben, weil der zweite
kommt dann auch dieselbe Kante in der nächsten Zeit. Genau,
so in etwa.
Das macht auch Clang-Format
bei C++ so.
Allerdings kann das,
und das macht glaube ich auch der Rust-Formatierer
in der Default-Einstellung und so. Das kann allerdings
witzige Seiteneffekte haben.
Nämlich möchtest du ja eigentlich deinen Autoformatierer
und auch hier Trailing oder Leading-Commerce
oder diese Pipes hauptsächlich haben,
damit du wenig Churn und Seiteneffekte
in deinem Git-Log hast.
Wenn ich unten was hinzufüge, muss ich
die vorherige Zeile mit anfassen.
Wobei ich mir denke, kann man da nicht
die Div-Tools schlau machen. Aber anyway.
Und was
dieses Einrücken
allerdings für einen Effekt hat, ist, dass wenn du
die Funktion umbenennst,
oder irgendwas anderes oder die Rückgabentyp änderst,
dann
ändert sich die Einrückung von dem ersten
Parameter und aller anderen auch
und dann hast du plötzlich fünf Zeilen angefasst.
Ja, obwohl GitDiff ja zumindest schon mal
ein White SpaceX suchen kann, wenn du möchtest.
Das ja auch als Standard so machen.
Das ist schon ganz clever so.
Kann Git Blame das auch?
Würde mich wundern, wenn nicht.
Weil der spannende Teil ist ja nicht,
was hat sich in diesem, also nicht nur,
was hat sich in diesem Commit alles geändert,
den ich gerade reviewen muss?
Sondern wer hat als letztes diese Zeile
angefasst und wenn dann da halt
da steht halt bei uns im Code ganz
häufig, irgendjemand irgendwann
vielleicht sogar irgendein Student
neue Formatierungsregeln
eingeführt.
Neuen Linter eingeführt.
Genau solche Sachen sind auch der Grund, warum Tab-Indentation
kacke ist, weil du da halt keine Parameter allein kannst.
Das geht halt nicht. Da musst du entweder Mix-Indentation
haben oder machst du nur Spaces.
Da hast du einfach logische Indentation.
Da ist halt einfach eine Indentation weiter. Da kannst du halt nichts
aneinander allein, machst du dann halt nicht.
Machst du, glaube ich, in Go geht dann halt nicht.
Die machen dann nicht drei
Tabs, weil sie vorher zwei hatten
und dann noch ein paar Spaces.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Ja, oder du gehst ja gleich
den coolen Weg und machst Fibonacci Inventation.
Da brauchst du dann schon so ein 21 zu 9
Display oder so. Ich behaupte ich.
Hast du das nicht?
Hast du eins?
Ich glaube nicht.
Fibonacci Inventation hat doch hier schon mal
hier wunderschön. Packe ich auch mit in die
Show Notes. Hier zeige ich euch kurz den Code, wie das ausschaut.
Ist doch einfach geil. Das sieht tatsächlich schick aus.
Vor allem ist es
es punisht halt Pyramid of Doom Code.
Also irgendwann ist der halt so weit rechts,
dass die nächste Ebene
plötzlich 30 Zeichen weiter. Gibt das irgendwie
als ESLint Plugin oder sowas?
Das hätte ich gerne.
Johannes hat bloß das Repo angefangen. Er wollte mal ein WIM-Plugin schreiben.
Hat er das
erfunden, oder wie?
Wir hatten aber drüber gesprochen gehabt.
Show Notes Fibonacci Initiation.
Geil. Das müsste sogar
relativ trivial einfach
ohne, dass du eine Syntax-Analyse
machst, auf bereits existierenden Code
anwendbar sein. Du nimmst einfach die
vorgegebene, also du weißt ja nicht,
du schaust, die minimale Einrückung
ist 4, also ist das wahrscheinlich alles
ein Vielfaches von 4 und dann gehst
du durch und machst einfach so ein Mapping von
8 auf 2 und von
12 auf 3 und von...
Was du auch machen kannst, ist, du machst es einfach
nicht von der Initiation der vorherigen Zeile abhängig,
sondern von der Zeihennummer und
punish so überlange Dateiköten.
Das ist halt
unlesbare Initiation, aber
Leute schreiben mal keinen Code hin und wenn
Dateien länger als 100 Zeichen sind.
Nächste Frage, soll eine Datei,
möchtest du lieber längere
Dateien oder viele kleine Dateien
haben? Ich möchte ein Mittelding.
Lesbare Dateien, aber nicht so was
wie, also keine
10.000, 20 Zeiler und
nicht so ein Ding wie, ich glaube das war die Telegram
Android App, die eine
Java-Klasse hatte, die war glaube ich eine
20.000-Zeilen-Datei. Und da steckte
alles drin. Die ersten 200 Zeilen
waren Imports. Das weiß ich noch.
Naja, bei Java kannst du dich ja nicht
wirklich entscheiden, weil bei Java ist ja jede Klasse zwangsläufig
eine eigene Datei. Das Info ist ja der Compiler sogar.
Ja.
Je nachdem, wenn du ganz viele
Tests in eine Datei wirfst, dann
kann die auch gerne mal... Man kann auch Code besser
strukturieren. Du hast da ja schon
Einfluss drauf.
Hat sonst noch jemand eine
Formatting-Horror-Story?
Wenn ihr, liebe Zuhörer,
Formatting Horror Stories habt,
dann schreibt uns die bitte
at akronomisierbar auf Twitter oder in unserem
Matrix-Titon.
Ja, ja, apropos Matrix.
Ich formatiert sie richtig.
Es sind ja inklusive wir
mittlerweile zwölf Leute im Matrix-Channel.
Finde ich sehr cool, dass da
auch hier geredet wird.
Mind blown.
Wahnsinn. Ich habe mir heute tatsächlich
auch einmal die Riot Desktop-App
installiert.
Gut, also wenn wir nicht noch sonderlich
viel mehr Themen haben,
weil wir nämlich gerade auch schon die
zwei Stunden Marke
erreichen. Dann wäre es aber ganz cool,
hier vielleicht langsam ein Ende zu finden.
Genau, also Sascha, das war sehr schön,
dass du endlich mal selber auf dieser Seite
des Mikrofons warst.
Spannende Frage, wirst du dir
diese Folge trotzdem sagen?
Was hörst du damit? Das kommt darauf
an, wie viele ihr noch bringt, bevor
ich das nächste Mal fahre wahrscheinlich.
Auf jeden Fall, sehr schön, dass du dabei warst.
Du bist in jeder Zeit immer wieder sehr willkommen hier.
War sehr lustig.
Dann können wir nämlich das nächste Mal auch mal über nicht
deine Arbeit reden, sondern vielleicht über andere Themen.
Und dann würde ich sagen, machen wir es an dieser Stelle zu.
Die Themen, die wir uns hier noch aufgeschrieben haben,
die nehmen wir uns einfach fürs nächste Mal als Over-Überhang mit rein.
Das war Akronomisierbar Folge 31.
Sascha, möchtest du den Countdown machen?
Die nächste Folge in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in 3.
Jetzt!
Gut, vielen Dank.
Luft an die Ohren.
Oh, ich habe ja gar nicht aufgenommen.
Ah!